[Music]
this channel was deemed too dangerous
and harmful by youtube but unfortunately
we think it violates our harmful and
dangerous policy it's important to us
that youtube is a safe place for all if
the content breaks our rules we remove
it
content that encourages illegal
activities that's right our show is so
dangerous that we encourage illegal
activities we have permanently removed
your channel from youtube that's right
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls you
are watching the most dangerous business
show in the world right here live on
youtube the taliban is allowed on
youtube the ccp is allowed on youtube
but the most dangerous business show is
not we were de-platformed and says going
forward you won't be able to access
possess or create any other youtube
channels they said we think this is not
good on our platform
and they would
we're able to completely delete the
channel and d-platform us
we were de-platformed
sometimes you just got to be the
dangerous guys dangerous [ __ ] yeah like
dangerous
the fact that we got cancelled off the
platform is absurd we were de-platformed
they were tweeting at susan after i told
her to call me she didn't call dangerous
[ __ ] they came for you john censored
yeah what's your job the most dangerous
giving away cash free education got
censored though listen here we the
captain now we're the captain now you
don't d-platform us we de-platform you
dangerous [ __ ] yeah the only thing i'm
willing to accept from the youtube team
the only thing is put us on the homepage
and give us another 250 000 subscribers
then we'll call it even fair trade fair
trade
dangerous [ __ ]
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome to the best business show also
now known as the most dangerous business
show in the entire world why is it the
best cause we said so why is it the most
dangerous because youtube said so i am
here with joe and john how do you know
their names are joe and john real simple
their names are on the back of their
chairs joey johnny jets ready to rock
and roll joe as you can tell has a
bottle of water ready to go i got two of
them but there is no
ads on this show for free
joe's going to stay hydrated john by the
way you don't have your coffee today but
you left the coffee cup in here last
night oh you didn't have a coffee yet no
i had coffee earlier oh so you got some
energy you're ready to go are you ready
i was up early today i had my coffee
earlier you got some juice today you
ready are you ready john's got yours
let's go can we get a little fourth
quarter all right low fourth quarter btc
is riding right now
all right we can start off real quick
there now the most dangerous business
show in the world we couldn't resist
obviously you saw the new intro we're
gonna play that a couple of times have a
little bit of fun with that matt did a
great job at the edit but i felt like if
we have the most dangerous business show
then you sitting at home might be the
most dangerous audience so what are we
gonna do for the most dangerous audience
well let's just lean into it let's enjoy
have a little bit of fun we now have the
world's most dangerous business show
merch that's right it took us an extra
day we tried to get it ready for
yesterday but now we are ready to go you
can go to
thebestbusinessshow.com and
joe looks real funny right there like
he's trying to peek over offensively
look at his neighbors i look good
wait are you guys gonna comment on your
face yeah it looks like i'm done looks
like i'm taking it
mine looks like
i look dangerous
you look dangerous or like you're taking
a poop dangerous
the world's most dangerous business
actually well you kind of you can yeah
more than anyone but you can go to
thebestbusinessshow.com and now you can
get the world's most dangerous business
show merch
don't say we've never done anything for
you
we have
big big plants what nah i was just
thinking uh someone said in the thing
that john looks high and i was thinking
don't do drugs kids
about the comment about like nothing
worse than looking
oh yeah what what
not just say it just say it there
there's a comment that someone told me a
while back that was there's nothing
worse than looking high and not even
being hot
[Laughter]
so if you're gonna look kyle you might
as well just enjoy it take it as it
however you wanted but i thought that
was funny all right nothing worse than
looking high and not being high
straight from john's friend's mouth
um all right here's what we're going to
be doing
we're going to do a giveaway today every
time we cross over 500 likes we're
giving out 250
now we have paid a lot of people out
there are a couple of people that we
still are trying to get money to we're
working on it don't worry we're coming
don't worry about it but about 80 of the
people so far already got it in the
banks bitcoin going up which means their
balance is going up too so when we get
to 500 likes 250 you get to a thousand
two fifty your job the content's free
all you have to do is smash the like
button and you can come here to learn
laugh and learn i like that joke i like
that joey got no shoes on nick carter is
coming into the studio later in person
joe will probably put his shoes back on
when nick gets here nick is the most
violent man on twitter i don't know if
you guys he doesn't make him look
violent but he's vying you write fud
nick will find him
[Laughter]
nick carter if you are writing nonsense
on the internet not only will he find
you but he will use his special skills
to absolutely destroy you he will take
you point by point to task he'll
literally just expose you for word
intellectual lightweight the most
violent man in the world is coming on
the most dangerous business show i'm not
saying it's worth watching but you might
want to stay tuned all right keep
smashing the like button and we will get
after it don't forget the best business
show has the best partner so far if you
go to sofi.com you can join the diamond
hands club the diamond hands club is a
very very good offer now what does it
mean you go there you open an account
you put two thousand dollars into the
account
and you basically now are aligned with
us what does that mean one we've got the
private slack two we will hold
periodic q and a's we're gonna bring
folks that we know from our network in
we're going to do calls we're going to
do interviews we're going to do q and
a's etc all for you to help learn more
about investing and about asset
management on top of that there's also
great merchandise and a whole bunch of
other stuff that we have planned
basically if you're outside the club
you're out if you're in the club you're
in you want to be in get on over to
sofi.com go sign up for an account get
your two thousand dollars in there if
you don't have two thousand dollars
that's okay no problem we're all about
opportunity you can start with as little
as five bucks and you can start to grow
that account and once you cross over
that threshold then all of a sudden you
will be in the program
yes i know no problem no problem no
problem we're ready to go anything you
guys want to talk about before we get
started
um don't care okay
now go ahead
all right let's start first with
fidelity fidelity is one of the largest
asset managers in the entire world and
they have been very bullish on bitcoin
for a while going back to 2014 2015
fidelity was bullish on bitcoin they
were trying to get exposure to bitcoin
the ceo abigail johnson actually had a
bitcoin miner in her office they have
been all over this they now though have
this director of global finance at
fidelity investments his name is jurian
timmer i believe i'm saying that
correctly and he has been the ultimate
bitcoin bull for a while he continues to
publish research him and his team he
continues to push forward the bitcoin
narrative he explains it from that
institution that asset manager uh
perspective why bitcoin is valuable how
it works how it fits into a portfolio
and what he thinks will happen in the
future
now
he has a brand new interview or clip
that has been circulating on twitter
that we're gonna play
and remember this is the director of
global finance at fidelity investments
when you hear what he is saying remember
this is not me this is not some random
person on the internet this is the
director of global finance at fidelity
here's what he had to say about bitcoin
and where he thinks it's going moving
forward
it's been a very stealthy
advance you know the what i what i would
define as the tourists so um uh holders
of bitcoin uh for less than three months
uh they're only at fifteen percent of
all coins held
and that is actually below where where
we see most bottoms happen so at the top
it was about 30 35
so this this has not been a momentum
fuel
run by short-term uh you know
speculators uh so that gives me some
confidence that this actually is a
pretty sustainable move and it's not you
know a bubble that's about to burst um
and you know as you point out um you
know 100k and i'm i know better than to
make bold price predictions
on the air and and certainly twitter
will do that for me anyway so i don't
need to but but i have a supply model
and a demand model and the next and last
time that those two models intersect is
at around 100k in a couple years and so
you know my sense is the the trajectory
is up and so far there really is no
evidence that this is a bunch of
momentum chasers um bringing this this
up to back to 57 and today more like 54.
now the director of global finance at
fidelity investments this is on national
television talking about on-chain
metrics supply shocks and calling for a
hundred thousand dollar bitcoin price we
have come so far my friends bitcoin was
launched on january 3rd 2009 literally
to nobody it was basically published and
no one knew about it nobody cared but
here we are about 12 years later almost
13 years later and the director of
global finance at fidelity investments
is shilling bitcoin on national tv but
he's not doing it in a way that it turns
off institutional investors actually
he's doing it exactly how you would
expect an institutional investor to
intelligently and rationally talk about
an asset that he believes is going to
approximately double as he says in a
couple of years now likely what he is
doing is under promising and trying to
over deliver we will see what happens
but to see him referencing things like
only 15 of the circulating supply has
moved in the last 90 days that is
directly from the on-chain metrics of
bitcoin the on-chain metrics are one of
the most valuable data sets in the
entire financial markets and so to see
him on there talking about it is pretty
damn cool we have this chart this is the
bitcoin supply and demand models that
supply and demand model shows that
bitcoin continues to move right along
that
logarithmic
growth pattern and so when you see this
it's the stock to flow it is this
logarithmic chart bitcoin continues to
do exactly what we expect it to do and
so if we go and we look at his explicit
quotes the first one says quote i really
don't think bitcoin threatens the dollar
or the dollar's reserve status bitcoin's
value proposition is that ultimately
goes from just being a store of value to
also being a medium of exchange and that
depends on second layer developments
that are being built right now
we have a second quote from them that
says maybe bitcoin actually further
ensures that the dollar will maintain
its reserve status because all of a
sudden currency is going to be available
in further flung reaches of the world
through bitcoin and it's still probably
going to be connected to the dollar in
some way
the director of global finance at
fidelity is not only talking about the
asset he's not only talking about the
on-chain metrics he's not only talking
about material price movements moving
forward he's also explaining the nuances
about the relationship on a relative
basis between bitcoin and the dollar and
how actually dollars may benefit from
the rise of bitcoin because now all of a
sudden dollars will be able to move
across the bitcoin rails similar to what
strike and twitter are doing and when
you start to understand that this is a
technology development and that there's
still work to do that developers today
and companies and entrepreneurs around
the world are all working tirelessly to
go ahead and push this forward you begin
to understand that this is not just an
asset that might go up in price it's not
just a thing that you buy and use it to
tell your friends at the bar
instead what we are talking about is a
piece of technology that is likely to
usher in economic prosperity for people
around the world those in the developing
world likely stand to gain more than
those in the developed world and also
there is going to be serious technology
innovation and ultimately disruption of
many of the incumbents because they will
continue to hold on to their legacy
position in the world they will not
go ahead and start to embrace this
until the challengers the startups those
that actually see the value today
already have a material head start so
what do we think the importance is of
somebody like this not only
understanding it but having the deep
conviction to go on television talk to
other institutional investors et cetera
with this level of uh sophistication and
conviction you know how they say like
started from the bottom now we here yeah
it was like the message boards now cnbc
right like i think it's cool i think
it's uh interesting that he obviously
has done a lot of work on it he's
talking about uh on-chain metrics all of
that kind of stuff so he's detailed in
it he's done a lot of homework i think
before he goes and makes announcements
like that but i also agree with your
point that uh he's he's uh under
promising and he wants to over deliver
right on on price i think anyone who has
looked at those metrics can uh see that
we're most likely going to go a lot
higher than 100 and much quicker than
2023 uh but it all depends right no one
knows for sure so i think he's probably
uh under promising a little there but i
still thought it was interesting he um
he's obviously bullish on the asset
class and i thought he was right about
kind of how it transitions to a payment
system right and he talks about some of
the layer 2 stuff i thought it was cool
to see him talk about how it can grow
but i think that he just was
underestimating what he probably
personally believes this could become to
stay kind of a little more bearish for
his clients correct john what do you
think
one thing to note is while he was
talking there was a rocket about a
launch so take that correlation however
you want
bitcoin's going to launch into space as
well we'll see
um but no fidelity's been massively
bullish for a long time now they were
releasing reports that it's going to go
to 100 million a coin um i'm surprised
to see him so bearish i think that he's
kind of taking the reserve route you
even heard him say look i don't want to
just say a ridiculous price prediction
people kind of track that stuff down um
you're notorious for price predictions
which is i've only i've made very few
price predictions and almost every
single one of them has been right i made
one in 2017 that was incorrect but other
than that almost all of them every other
one has been really accurate yeah
pretty good i make a bunch of price
predictions too i just follow plan b's
model and i say this is check check
check we didn't have we didn't have
stock to flow uh at that point i mean
that was now we're almost five years ago
uh 2017. oh i you make like yearly per
annual predictions i make monthly ones
all right so the other piece of this
that i think is really important is now
many of the folks who go on um
television who go to conferences who
speak at on these private webinars et
cetera the institutional investors uh
they're also armed with more information
right so yeah yeah it's fun for us to
joke around and be like oh in 2016 2017
2018 whatever people thought x or y uh
but now that there's these models out
there that there's actually been a ton
more work there's more people
scrutinizing that work which means that
it gets better there's more uh
understanding of on chain metrics
there's places like glassnode who have
done a great job in terms of being able
to gather data present it allow folks to
analyze it and then there's been a lot
of work obviously we've seen uh will
clemente create a number of different uh
metrics ratios using that on-chain
metrics we've seen folks like david puel
he also has created some stuff willie wu
same thing uh and now even you have
folks like dylan leclair et cetera who
are all starting to uh to really become
uh big proponents of this of these data
sets and so what ultimately i think is
happening here is we have an asset it's
obviously gone through adoption of the
institution or of the individuals now
it's into the institutional adoption
cohort we're starting to creep into the
nation-state cohort but what you're also
seeing is people are peeling it back
they're starting to really really
understand what drives demand what is
the uh the um kind of uh repercussions
of the supply schedule and the
programmatic monetary policy um and
ultimately that is really important for
institutions to continue to adopt this
right they have to be able to if you're
uh institutional cio a chief investment
officer you've got to be able to not
only one understand the asset two you've
got to be able to articulate that uh
investment thesis and writing in your
investment memo et cetera but then
you've got to be able to have the
conviction and confidence and frankly
have the command of the nuance to have
conversations with your investors or
with your colleagues or with peers in
your industry so if all of a sudden
let's say that you are some large
institution
fidelity is a great example they have
investors and so their investors call
this hey what do you guys think about
this bitcoin stuff we see you talking
about it all the time like explain it to
me okay what is it how does it work why
are we bullish on it what are the risks
what are the mitigations to those risks
what do we think about the regulatory
regime like there's so much to unpack
and so
the more that this industry becomes
developed the more likely it is that uh
those answers kind of get open sourced
and people start to to understand it and
so now if you look at stock to flow like
if we didn't have the stock to flow
ratio
there would be a ton of people trying to
figure out well what do i think the
programmatic monetary supply is going to
do with the demand and how does that
affect price moving forward now all of a
sudden there's been a bunch of folks who
have all kind of coalesced and agreed on
hey this is likely to be the right model
again it could be invalidated at some
point it could be wrong but when you
have that now you've got a way that
people can clearly articulate it so if i
said you guys well stock to flow you
immediately know what that chart says
right you already understand what the
supply
components are what the demand
components are and what the price
implications are and so i think that
more and more that's going to get
developed over time what's fascinating
to me is that if fidelity starts to
actually be the one putting out the
research if fidelity is the one that
starts to create some of this uh it's
very different than if
some unknown person on twitter does it
right the bitcoin community has prided
themselves on the fact that anyone
whether you're known or sued anonymous
whether you're super experienced or
you're completely amateur
if you create good work if there's a
meritocracy your work will rise to the
top but there is still in the
institutional world value put on who
created the work so we saw square come
out with a bunch of research we've seen
arc come out a bunch of research
fidelity has put stuff out and there's a
bunch of other organizations now doing
that as well the more that we can get
them putting out research themselves i
think again it just provides more
legitimacy it's more career risk cover
meaning that people don't feel like
they're going to get fired for
allocating to it you'll see more public
companies start trying to actually put
on their balance sheet and overall it's
just a big net positive to not only have
them involved not only have them talking
about it but also to have them really
driving some of the research as well
because they have experience doing it
and they have legitimacy in certain
circles yeah like the psychology behind
this the human psychology is fascinating
right because if you just think over the
last few years bitcoin within
traditional circles and kind of the
traditional finance community was
something that you didn't really talk
about right like it was known as this
kind of weird thing on the internet that
people talked about on message boards
and i think uh if you were kind of a
traditional uh person in finance whether
you worked on fixed income equities
whatever it was and you told people that
you worked with three four five years
ago that you were buying bitcoin you had
a significant allocation to it they
would have called you crazy it would
have been weird and they wouldn't have
they would have judged you quite frankly
right and i think today that psychology
of having people like fidelity having
other people go on cnbc and talk about
it understand the models understand the
metrics all that helps right the only
thing that i didn't necessarily agree
with and i'm curious what your opinion
is that he said uh bitcoin doesn't
fundamentally threaten the dollar's
reserve status
what do you think that it does
yeah i mean i think it does right and i
think it's interesting though that he uh
basically explained it as like something
that could be that was so far off right
and i know that's one of the things that
you
uh believe in pretty strongly so i'm
curious to think like where do you think
the disconnect is with him understanding
that i don't think that it uh i don't
think that it threatens the dollar in
the short to medium term and i don't
think it threatens the dollar in the way
that most people think it does like i
really do think strike and uh twitter
are proving that bitcoin rails
are
so valuable to the dollar right all of a
sudden now if i take a dollar and i try
to send it to anyone else in the world
via any of these other platforms they're
all closed networks i want to send a
dollar within the banking network i can
do it but it's a closed network if you
don't have one of the banks you can't
receive the dollars if i want to do it
inside of venmo or paypal or cash app or
wherever again it's all closed networks
the second that i now can send a dollar
via an open monetary network
really really powerful and then the
other piece that a lot of people don't
realize about this is and strike has
kind of pioneered this is through
twitter right now if i want to send
let's say john dollars right i can go on
to twitter i can basically say send john
one dollar when i send that dollar
they're using the lightning network so
it's literally taking dollars from my
account it is essentially converting it
into bitcoin it's sending bitcoin across
the light network it's converting it
back into dollars right and depositing
with john that sounds like okay you're
sending dollars across the lightning
network and there's some plumbing and
the everyday person has no clue that the
bitcoin rails are being used for the uh
twitter stuff now what becomes really
interesting is well what if i want to
send dollars to john but john doesn't
want to receive dollars john instead
wants to receive euros now all of a
sudden i press a button i get my account
debited for dollars and john then gets
credited euros on his end and so now
what you've done is you've not only
opened up the rails from an open
monetary network standpoint but you've
also made the fiat currencies
interoperable with each other
and most people say oh they've been
interoperable well kind of what normally
you've had to do is you've literally had
to go to the bank and exchange them
yourself right there's really high fees
all that type of stuff or what would
happen is i could send john dollars and
then john could withdraw from his bank
in euros etc but what this is actually
allowing it for to do is reduce the
friction even further and drastically
reduce the cost of switching in between
fiat currencies and so what we do know
is that if you can actually reduce cost
if you can reduce friction the fiat
currency value proposition actually
increases because now you have
interoperability between them but
they're all doing this and going across
these bitcoin rails with lightning
network rails and it becomes a really
really interesting value proposition so
it's counterintuitive in terms of uh how
bitcoin and the dollar are uh related
now with that said there's a lot of
people who say okay true
but there is a specific area where
bitcoin is uh um you know providing
something that the dollar doesn't which
is in the store of value right so
obviously if i hold dollars and it's a
historic monetary kind of devaluation
then i'm going to lose purchasing power
over time we've already been losing
purchasing power but now it's kind of
being accelerated so if i hold instead
in this finite asset that should protect
or appreciate my purchasing power that
is more of a competitive thing but i do
think that what ultimately is going to
happen here is people are going to look
back and say wow the dollar's ability to
be sent across these rails was
completely misunderstood and
underestimated and so for the short to
the medium term this is going to be a
boom for the dollar uh and then
ultimately over time we're going to see
what happens with fiat currencies in
general um i don't think we can predict
out 50 plus years that's really hard but
i do think that people misunderstand the
relationship in the short term and i
think that's what he's ultimately
getting at which again speaks the fact
that he's actually really really
educated on this stuff and understands
it the difference between what he was
saying and what jamie dimon was saying
was like night and day right you can
just tell they have two completely
different understandings and have done
two completely different sets of
homework when it comes to who would you
bet
not jamie diamond
right john yeah it's interesting that
you talk about that because
basically in the short to medium term
people are always gonna hold fiat
currencies in their bank account um
because they need them to transact right
but you can use those the lightning
network the bitcoin like rail network to
kind of send it in a faster manner um
and basically instantly cross borders
low fees all that stuff so it's
interesting to see your thinking process
on it um but that's that's part of the
tooth like the mindset that i i know you
guys agree with but that i i always
think about is like people need to get
out of the mindset of saving in fiat
currency right because at the end of the
day you can save in bitcoin like
literally uh isaiah was on here
yesterday he said 90 of my savings isn't
bitcoin he didn't call an investment he
said my savings account is bitcoin right
so
you're you're guaranteed within the us
dollar you're guaranteed over time we've
seen it and like you said it's been
accelerating now over the last 12 uh or
24 months you're guaranteed to lose
purchasing power right if you keep it in
dollars and you just keep it sitting in
your account so keep an emergency fund
keep you know three six months whatever
you need for you and your family to make
sure everything is okay but ultimately
bitcoin can become your savings account
because it's something that not only
maintains your purchasing power as a
store of value but is actually
appreciated at what was it 200 annually
over the last decade so right it's it's
been uh fundamentally a much better
savings account than the us dollar has
served
we hit 500 likes on the count of three
free content you got to press the like
button ready we cross over a thousand
we're gonna give out money one two three
press the like button let's get over
1000 likes
the first amount of money we're gonna
give out i'm gonna send i think i can
only do actually 99 through twitter but
right now i want you after you press the
like button i want you to drop your
twitter handle in the youtube chat we're
gonna pick one person i'm gonna send you
99 right now across twitter i'm
literally gonna send it to you across
twitter right now on the spot if you
have twitter tips enabled i'm going to
send you 99
right this second because we hit that
500k but i need to know you got to have
it actually uh enabled in order for me
to do it so i'm going to quickly pick
somebody or you say the winner make sure
they have it enabled well let's just
check real quick all right so uh what do
we think about twitter's ability to do
this how bullish are we on this for
bitcoin like the impact on bitcoin i'm
super bullish on it i think like uh
like
the
involvement of people that run these
major networks is underestimated right
like when
jack dorsey is someone who believes in
bitcoin and believes in the network uh
and the infrastructure and the future of
the asset that's a massive asset when it
comes to the community of bitcoin and
the future prospect of bitcoin right he
he runs a network not only square cash
up all that kind of stuff aside but with
twitter there's 330 or 350 million
active users each month he just in the
flick of a switch enabled tipping for
them across across the lightning network
right and it's a massive uh ability for
bitcoin to scale to uh scale much
quicker so i think not only when it
comes to twitter but getting people like
jack and other people that run these
massive networks on our side uh would be
extremely helpful going forward he just
took a social media platform and made it
a payment platform as well
it's amazing it's also great for
creators on the platform uh it was
originally designed probably for those
remittance payments but it's great that
you can
kind of just transaction send tips and
and do all that stuff that uh i feel
like users have wanted on that platform
for a long time and he's using bitcoin
to do it i i got one problem though i
haven't been getting a lot of tips
nobody sent me a lot of tips i only got
you know a couple tips in there but done
first one done already at underscore
dylan heath underscore
bam i just sent you 99
worth of bitcoin via twitter i went
right to his uh actual congrats dylan
twitter tips and just sent him way
easier you see you just get paid bam
right there 99 worth of bitcoin by the
way somebody just sent me a temp tip and
said 1.99
i'm not saying who it was but that was
pretty good that was very very slick
dylan you win the first one we just hit
a thousand dollars as well uh or a
thousand likes now i'm gonna give out
another hundred dollars so again comment
your twitter account right this second
i'm gonna pick one more person and send
another 99.
to somebody via bitcoin over twitter on
the twitter tips who are we gonna pick
how should we try you get a hundred
dollars you get 100. by the way dylan he
said my boys
got you that's fine a little case of
beer on us maybe a little dinner
whatever you want man just thank you we
appreciate you watching the show who are
we going to give 99 to right now let's
see
who is going to win the next one
all right i already got somebody let's
see here who's gonna win it who's gonna
win it
who's gonna win it
ah i'm gonna lose it oh there it is um
all right so joe and john when we think
about the uh fidelity if you're running
fidelity right now what would you do to
help facilitate bitcoin going forward
well i think clearly there's client
demand right we've seen that not only
across fidelity but all the other
institutions uh jamie dimon was saying
that he doesn't believe in it but his
clients do and that's what makes markets
he's right in that instance right like
if your clients are doing it even though
you don't believe in you have to provide
products for them as the ceo of that
business to help invest them i think
what fidelity is doing is they're going
to start providing a bunch of research
they're going to start providing a bunch
of products we know that they're trying
to get involved in the etf uh if you
have someone who is running that
business that believes in it and is
actively educating themselves on it
maybe he's just doing it so he can talk
to clients he can appropriately service
his clients et cetera but ultimately
what it does is it creates an
infrastructure where
clients are asking for these things
right and when clients are asking for it
you need to you need to help facilitate
that demand and whether it's research or
any of the other things i just mentioned
i think what we're going to see is this
is going to continue to get adopted by
institutions right and it's going to
become much more of a traditional
product uh in their eyes than they would
have thought before so they're going to
do all the research they're going to do
all these things where their clients can
actively start trading this stuff they
can get educated on it and they get yeah
sure the fi the firms the legacy
companies and banks are going to make
money on it but at the end of the day
the clients are asking for this stuff so
i think uh the banks that do a really
good job and facilitate the needs of
these clients will move forward and
benefit from this and the ones that
don't will fall backwards well the ones
that don't they might uh they might run
into a wall where clients are just like
cool so you take my money out of the
pool
your aum is automatically lower and i'm
going to go somewhere else that can
actually service the needs and the
investments that i want
chettin
sparkling pm bam done 99 bucks a bitcoin
right there i didn't even sparkling pm
let's go
there's another one i don't need a bank
we don't need a bank we don't need them
in order for me to send that money right
there that is the beauty of this new
system is literally somebody dropped
their twitter handle on the chat i went
to their twitter account and i
immediately sent them 99 worth of
bitcoin like that that is the future of
the system we do not need anybody to be
that middleman that permissioned
gatekeeper that is the beauty why is
there a cap on tips on twitter
uh i think there's only a cap on certain
types of it i think i could send
actually as much bitcoin as i want i
just got a dollar tip as i started to uh
look at it i think it's only with the
dollars uh there's a cap but with the
bitcoin because actually uh you're
sending on uh when you send bitcoin
you're actually sending bitcoin across
twitter is what i uh as i'm using it
more i think what you're doing is you're
basically uh assigning a bitcoin wallet
address to the
twitter account and then when i go in i
am copying the bitcoin wallet address
i'm then going into strike shout out
strike uh and then i basically
paste the bitcoin wallet address and
then i'm sending it there so i don't
think you're actually going through
twitter instead what twitter has enabled
is not only to be able to send it across
twitter via strike but also there's
other uh forms of payment as well so you
can actually do venmo you can do cash
app or you can do uh the bitcoin wallet
address attached shout out to aunt
skibs1 just got my first dollar tip from
him
he said here you go joe
all right make sure you keep smashing
the like button if we hit 1.5 k we'll
give out mo cash money
vladimir putin the leader of russia says
that he now accepts that crypto has a
role in making payments and that crypto
quote has a right to exist which is a
pretty crazy thing to be saying uh
cryptocurrency has the right to exist
and can be used as a means of payment
now he explicitly has said that the bank
of russia uh or i'm sorry the bank of
russia has explicitly continued to say
that they're issuing warnings to
investors that the crypto market is
extremely volatile and also that they
usually will not allow anyone to use
digital currencies for payments internal
to the country domestically now we have
the two quotes from vladimir putin the
first is i believe that it is value but
i don't believe it can be used in the
oil trade so very important the russian
president now has said that he does
believe that it has value but he doesn't
believe it can be used in the oil trade
this was via an interview that was
posted to the government website the
second one is he says this dollar is a
competitive advantage it is a universal
reserve currency in the united states
today uses it to pursue political goals
and they harm their strategic and
economic interest as a result now what
is very interesting about russia and
china both is that they have openly
talked about the dollar system and how
the us's control of the global reserve
currency ends up actually putting them
at a disadvantage they even has gone as
far as to say vladimir putin has
explicitly stated that he would like to
get off of the dollar system now could
he actually do that remains to be seen
but that is his goal and so to see him
say something like this around the
dollar being a competitive advantage is
not surprising at all also remember that
the russian central bank had started to
sell all or most of their dollars they
also have explicitly said that they were
going to strategically change their
capital allocation structure to other
non-dollar assets now where they are in
that process remains to be seen inside
of russia you can see that the rising
inflation likely has brought bitcoin and
cryptocurrencies to the forefront so you
can see that inflation level as of
september is at
7.4 percent again this is the official
numbers according to the central bank of
russia so their official numbers are
showing 7.4 percent inflation which is
higher than the united states so anytime
you start to get that high level of
inflation it is likely to show you that
there is some value in these other
assets and so to see an interview with
the president of russia posted on the
government website where he explicitly
states that it has value and that he
believes that it should have a right to
exist is very interesting because he's
likely advocating for potentially some
sort of
participation from either the government
people within the country or
corporations within the country so we do
not yet know what their plans are we do
not know whether they are good or bad
but we do know that now uh this is some
public commentary saying that it has the
right to exist it can be used as a means
of payment and he believes that it does
have value so do we think that this is
like a big story or is this kind of
duh of course uh he thinks that it
should exist duh he thinks it could be
used for payments and duh he thinks it
has value i don't take any of that for
granted right really i think this is
like a non-story really i mean i think
it's a non-story in the fact that
there's no real uh there's no real
tangible thing that came out of it right
he just said it's early and it could be
used on the road and we'll see right so
uh and he says it could be an acceptable
form of payment sure great but i don't
take uh any of like the i mean he's one
of the most powerful men in the world
right he could be the richest man in the
world we don't really know uh so i think
anytime you get those people talking
about the asset and like i said before
it's the human psychology behind it
right like all these important big
people talking about it is good in the
long run whether they're saying positive
things or negative things it's bringing
the asset into light uh to people that
may not have been educated on previously
and when people go down that rabbit hole
as everyone watching and we know you
start to find things out and you start
to realize things and things start to
make sense in your head and you start to
buy the asset right so i think uh putin
talking about it and saying that he
could see it being a form of payment
down the road whether it's for oil or
something else and saying it's still
early is great i uh i don't necessarily
know if it's a non-story but yeah you're
right it's not there was no tangible uh
kind of thing that came out of this that
we can point to and say hey look this is
drastically gonna increase the price but
i think the when you look at in totality
all of these things right the fidelity
uh the head of fidelity talking about it
putin everyone else talking about it
kind of over time period you start to
see like these things add up and it's
really important uh that these people
come on our side no surprise russia
wants to move away from the dollar right
um what kind of shocked me is i don't
forex trade or anything like that so
seeing russia's inflation rate being
close to 18 in 2015 was actually very
shocking to me they obviously have way
higher inflation than we do um they have
consistently moved away from the dollar
i would not be surprised if they go into
bitcoin and when they go into bitcoin
they go into bitcoin hard and really
fast with a lot of money because they're
seeing it appreciate over time with um
with just the the dollar appreciation
right so they don't want anything that's
correlated to the us dollar
understandable the thing i don't like is
uh is hearing uh putin and russia talk
about bitcoin like they're about to ape
into the asset class while we sit around
and uh and i haven't heard anything from
most of our higher up governments we're
working on regulations they make
gas peddle it
so the idea of what you're saying is
that if russia was all of a sudden start
openly acquiring bitcoin you think that
would put the united states at a huge
disadvantage and so again the global
game theory is around uh who's going to
be first to do this at a developed
nation standpoint yeah like you
mentioned before how much the u.s would
be at an advantage if they just took one
percent of their budget and went and
acquired bitcoin with it right like i
think there's a massive advantage we
talk about it uh in investing in
technology companies and startups all
the time it's like that first mover
advantage is huge and i think when it
comes to bitcoin and asset that has a a
fixed and constrained supply if you're
able to get a large amount or require a
large amount of the of the outstanding
bitcoin or the network currently uh at
this price i think you're going to be
really really really happy down the road
and i think whatever developed nation is
able to do that and has the resources to
go be able to do that at the time being
i think as a first mover they're gonna
have a huge advantage well there's kind
of two different schools of thought
right there's the accumulation game
where we're just gonna go try to acquire
as much bitcoin as possible and hold it
there's also kind of what el salvador
did where they did a little bit of
accumulation but they really kind of
mass produced it as a medium of exchange
in their country so there's two
different ways that they can go about it
i don't see russia just basically using
it as a medium exchange and trying to
apply it across uh their entire
population i see more of an accumulation
game you know what i get it i think uh i
think he already owns it
oh i have no doubt that i mean look i
forget what the country was whether it
was the ukraine or somebody they
basically had to do disclosures for
politicians and it came out they all had
a bunch of bitcoin like not not shocking
at all um and my guess is that also
politicians in the united states
obviously we know own it uh but there's
politicians in france and uh uh spain
and in the uk that own it and then also
in switzerland in uh various countries
in uh africa in india in china in russia
do you think the u.s government owns
bitcoin currently well they definitely
own bitcoin but it's not because they
went and they bought it as like a
strategic investment they took it yeah
they seized it from uh folks in criminal
investigations but did they sell it uh
they have sold most of what they have
seized over the years uh but they
definitely still have some the other
thing is and remember this is uh a piece
no one ever really talks about but the
united states government absolutely has
acquired bitcoin either through small
purchases or actually through mining um
and i'm 100 sure that they have mined uh
inside of some of these um law
enforcement agencies uh because they use
it as part of their undercover
investigations so if all of a sudden you
need to buy something on the dark web
and you they only accept bitcoin we have
to get your hands on some bitcoin in
order to be able to use it so you can
either buy it you can seize it from
somebody you can mine it whatever but
it's similar to let's say that the uh
law enforcement agency wants to go do a
drug bust right where are they dollars
where they get the dollars from right
it's somehow they went and got dollars
then they go and they use that money as
part of the drug bust and do it now
what's fascinating uh but also scary as
hell
is if they're doing this and they're
sending bitcoin transactions and then
they're watching it permeate through the
blockchain then all of a sudden you get
in a world where you say to yourself
okay we may actually not know
uh who are the good actors and bad
actors right and so there's this whole
world that like i frankly don't really
understand all the details but like
that's absolutely happening here as well
it's just does that really count as like
the government's holding it i don't
think that when people think of like oh
you made a strategic allocation a la uh
el salvador the uss hasn't done that i
don't think
my
my thing is with the putin thing like
we don't really know how much money he
has right some people estimate versus
man in the world some say some say
richest man in the world some say 50
billion some say 100 billion i i think
he has a billion dollar house which
would be absurd uh but yeah he's
obviously got a lot of money so i don't
understand um from the purchasing power
aspect of like who can go in and just
buy a [ __ ] ton of this a bitcoin like
he's right up there with elon bezos all
these guys that we talk about all the
time in america when you have that much
money this is basically uh i think
chamath palpatine one time said schmuck
insurance it's just like look uh
allocate one i'm gonna buy a little bit
of everything cool you guys think that
uh seashells are gonna become a currency
that's important in the world yeah if i
buy 500 million dollars of seashells
literally it's a rounding error like
doesn't even matter and you just do it
more so from a defensive standpoint than
like an offensive standpoint right and i
think that's a key piece of this by the
way we've now given two people free
bitcoin today i just reloaded my account
i'm ready to rock and roll reload rock
and roll like i just like to get johnny
hit him
business show
no problem no problem
the problem dangerous show in the world
loaded reloaded don't worry we just
reloaded so you keep pressing the like
button we'll keep shelling out bitcoin
what do you guys think the percent
chance is uh by the end of the weekend
that we hit a new all-time high i i
think you book it book it get it it's
done okay book it oh
my god
i don't trade yeah financial yeah but
this is no terms and conditions
i think that there is more than an 80
chance by the end of the weekend we hit
a new all-time high and it's driven by
three things one once we broke through
58 000
it's likely then that there's nothing
else there's no more resistance till the
new all-time high the second thing is
you can feel that the sentiment online
has shifted from one that was super
bearish to now it's very bullish and you
can start to see that uh in the way that
people are tweeting and talking about it
etc people are coming out of the
woodwork to go talk on national
television now like the whole game is
being played the third thing is that you
can see on chain that we are starting to
see a little bit of large holders they
started to sell just a little bit of
their holdings which means that they
think that we're starting to move
upwards and they'll sell into the
strength uh and then actually one other
thing is you can look and see on the
various order books that there's a ton
of buy support coming in and so when you
add up those factors it's not a
guarantee but over 80 confidence by the
end of the weekend we hit an all-time
high
why are you smiling because i'm locked
and loaded
ready to go
that would be nice
yeah it's just um it's one of these
things by the way if it's not right i'm
not going to do anything different again
i don't i don't trade on any of this
stuff but like if you just said to me
okay you have to make a choice is it or
is it not like over eighty percent but
still it's twenty percent likely that it
doesn't happen so if we come back on
monday and we're like oh it had hasn't
happened yet and it waits till the end
of that week i was off by four or five
days like okay yeah it doesn't change
any long-term thinking at all but i just
get a little better mood you know i like
i don't like hearing the the bears talk
all day on twitter i gotta stop i gotta
stop watching the price dude i look at
it every day knowing that i'm not gonna
do anything even with the price why do
you do that why you do it why do i look
at the price yeah every day multiple
times a day multiple times
all day long ladies and gentlemen up and
down ladies and gentlemen welcome to an
example of what not to do nah i look at
it but i know that no matter what it
could go down by 20 or it could go up by
20 and i'm still not going to do
anything the only thing i'll even
probably be incentivized to do is if it
went down a significant amount i'd
probably try to buy more yeah so you you
have long-term conviction but you're
just interested in this yeah i'm just
interested it's like a dope dopamine hit
free yeah and she's like ooh why not
[Laughter]
you guys gonna tell me you guys gonna
stand here sit here and tell me you
don't look at the price every day i look
at the price probably
one maybe two times a day
twice when you wake up like in the
morning and in the afternoon or night
yeah okay how many that's basically what
i do when i wake up i look at it uh and
then um i pretty much the only other
time i'll look at it is if uh i see a
bunch of people tweeting about something
and then i'll be like oh something's
going on and i'll go check yeah because
it's like you're missing the contacts
right i don't have a live stream of the
price like on my on my tv i don't know
bro you said he was going like this you
were looking at it like that bang bang
we just hit 1.5 k likes i also think
like the volatility has been lessened a
lot over the last few months so there
was a period of time where we weren't
really moving joe do not get loads of
sleep baby do not get ready to go the
rocket john's talking about the rocket
going to the moon is i'm ready i told
you locked and loaded
bitcoin went from 64 000 dropped down to
30 000
and now it's back at 57 58 000 and
people are acting like it's had 32. like
the whole world is asleep
and that's what you need the whole world
is asleep
and it just creeps back
and then for the next three months you
ain't going to be able to sleep listen
that's the quietest almost 2x in all of
financial markets from 30 000 almost 60
000
and literally we didn't make a peep
ain't nobody wake up they're all still
asleep they got the vagina every single
wall street banker that doesn't have any
bitcoin is like oh that stupid thing is
back at 32. oh [ __ ] it's that made up
60. you made a good point i i i'm the
outlier i disagree with most of that
what do you do you think it's been dead
quiet
bro
go on the street right now and ask
people what bitcoin's price is nobody
thinks that 60k that's because half the
people in america don't even know what
bitcoin is still okay they're asleep
next so it might be great but if a stock
doubles in price ain't no one talking
about it on youtube
i talk to investors all day long and
there are multiple investors that i've
talked to this week who had no clue that
bitcoin was almost at sixty thousand
the same dollars of people talking about
what it wouldn't be any more number of
people talking about tesla or if amazon
doubled in price people might talk about
it but if you're involved in the world
you're involved in the world anyways
it's not like you're just going to be
like oh like what'd you guys say about
it tesla doubled right now and it
happened in a 90-day period nobody would
shut up about it yeah but you're picking
an asset that's very
it's very social driven
okay amazon doubled no one would stop
talking about it
if peloton doubled
wait wait what are you talking about all
day huh what are you talking about
you talk about bitcoin all day and so
does everyone else on the internet
everyone knows where it's at we're going
to the moon speaking bitcoin true all
right we just hit 1.5 k likes here's
what we're gonna do ready i need you to
do two things in the chat we're gonna
pick one person and we're gonna give
them 99 of bitcoin right now live on the
show the way that we're gonna do that is
for
you have to comment not only your
twitter account but also i want you to
comment with what is your end of year
price prediction for bitcoin end of your
price prediction for bitcoin and your
twitter account in the same thing and
i'll pick one person let's go we're
gonna give out free bitcoin nowhere else
in the world do you come to learn laugh
and earn real simple end of year what do
you think the price is and what is your
twitter account
i just like picking random people tom
can we tell them about your your news
no
damn we can't tell him no john's got
news john's got news john's got no
reason to even bring this up no i'll
tell you in a few weeks no no no no no
no
no
no
no
no no no all right john don't want to
talk i don't want to tell y'all why
don't you just come up with like some
other news story than just a kind of
film i don't want to lie to him no yeah
i don't lie but i don't understand why
you won't tell them because it doesn't
matter
don't matter that's not dumb oh not done
deal true not done not done not done i
know john is not releasing uh music i do
have one announcement that john and i
wanted to talk about uh to the viewers
i'm out you don't know you are out no
you are literally out of this yes you
are out
john and i are taking applications uh
for our union if you want to join the
union of the best businesses let us know
please let john and i know tweet at us
we're working on the benefits we'll have
all the details out soon uh but we're
gonna unionize this we're tired of
getting treated like like crap right
like we come up here every day we get
treated like [ __ ] and i'm sure you guys
are too so uh let us know and we will we
will unionize together feel horrendous
we don't want people that are going to
break out the union and get bribed in
all this stuff we need people that are
fighters are you the doe the union
delegate i'll i'll be there i'll be the
head of you yeah no we're both the
co-heads what does the union do
go on strike
[Music]
we do one thing
we fight for our people we get better
benefits we get better pay we get
vacation time we get medical care and we
go on strike if we don't get it be ready
dude what are you talking about this is
the research team as well the union so
research team union whatever there's one
person over there i would be really sad
to lose from the research team the other
person i think we would survive without
he got real quiet i didn't get quiet i
made fun of your laugh
all right i've tried problems
i've tried six different people i've
tried six different people that they're
probably all
they don't have
they don't have tips enabled stop
commenting if you don't have tips you
don't have tips enabled i can't help you
i'm trying my best yeah you can just
keep commenting
until i find somebody who actually has
it or some of these price predictions
john what's up with the next topic all
above 100.
um bitcoin etf what's going on there arc
investments has lend out its name for a
new etf that wants to invest in bitcoin
futures not just to hold the asset
bitcoin um arc the arc 21 shares bitcoin
futures strategy etf plans to invest in
bitcoin future contracts that are that
trade on a commodity exchange so it's a
little different than a traditional etf
there's about i think nine bitcoin
futures etf applications that are
considered by u.s regulators at
beginning this month you can see here
who's involved in the etf alpha
architect a white label insurer of the
etf submitted the filings and then 21
shares us llc an affiliate of zug
switzerland based 21 shares ag is listed
as a subadvisor and then arc kathy wood
and arc investment management has agreed
to provide marketing support for the sub
advisors so their name is kind of just
attached to it i'm sure they're going to
get some kickback of some sort um but
yeah they are getting into the etf
futures game what do you think about
future evenings i want to know uh like
how these arrangements work like i don't
know much about this i need to look this
up about like how much uh kathy wooden
are like are they being paid for this or
she just getting equity oh she's an
investor she's an ambassador and she
also i believe sits on the board yeah so
she owns equity by the way i'm an
investor in this yeah why didn't you say
that before well because i would what
you guys were over thanks for the heads
up dude yeah
i always do that
sounds like something i'd like to invest
in let me read one let me read one a
moon is a a business there's a moon and
there's 21 shares uh that they have uh
built an asset management firm the asset
management firm
pioneered in europe etps right exchange
traded products uh similar to an etf but
not exactly an etf and what they allowed
people to do first was to go long
individual assets so a bitcoin
etp etc and then eventually they created
inverse etps which lets you buy an asset
buy like a stock but it gives you short
exposure so i think bitcoin's gonna go
down rather than go try to figure out
how to actually short it i just buy this
stock and it gives me short exposure
pretty cool then what they started to do
was now they're uh i actually don't know
if i'm allowed to say what the new plan
like the additional plans are what the
next thing they're going to do but they
have other things that they're going to
go start to do similar idea in different
venues and as part of that kathy wood
invested in a moon and she joined the
board of directors and so she what are
you laughing at who
who invested for you or her
me who
but
sorry i don't want to i don't want to be
real it doesn't it doesn't matter but i
don't care yeah yeah but but uh i mean
by the way like i was like this is like
amazing for the business we should
absolutely do the best we can i really
as most people know i really really
respect kathy um and the work that
they've done
and so now what they're doing is they're
launching this i believe it's a futures
etf uh or an application and it's arc
plus uh
uh the business going and uh moon
operates 21 shares yes correct okay
yeah so pretty good hani uh rashwan has
been on the uh uh has been on the
podcast before mol i think two or three
times do you think future etfs like uh
bitcoin future etfs are better or worse
than traditional ets and like are they
good for the market i'm assuming they
are
uh yeah look i think
all of these financial products are
going to be positive the uh negative is
uh
[Music]
if you can get direct exposure and if
you don't get direct exposure there
could be a cost difference or there
could be are you actually getting true
price uh exposure or not so if bitcoin
goes up let's say 2x and your vehicle
exposure only goes up 80 percent of that
then actually it would better have
direct exposure than not so you can
directionally follow it but does it
actually mirror it and then two is the
cost structure right that's the other
big big issue uh hey jordy nick is here
uh let's get nick and we're gonna bring
we're not even going to commercial today
we're not doing any of it if you guys
want free bitcoin go to sofi.com
go and buy 10 bitcoin when you go to
sofi.com you buy 10 bitcoin they give
you 10 for free it's a no-brainer if you
don't win the giveaways 10 of bitcoin
for everybody if you just go to
software.com
download the app create an account and
buy towns bitcoin i don't know i didn't
want to derail that conversation but
this is exactly why we need a union
you're over here investing in etfs you
know when we didn't get any we didn't
get a chance to do that john you know
what you were still working at a bank
when i did you know you know what's
funny is i
first the first bitcoin etf was filed i
think in what 2013 and the sec hasn't
approved these because they cite
concerns about fraud and manipulation
the sec citing concerns about fraud and
manipulation they manipulate markets
okay hold on hold on let's back let's
back oh there he is
there he is
we will talk about etfs later nick is
here live in the flesh what's up man am
i late no you're early you're early five
minutes early look when you show up we
stopped the show like we're ready to
rock and roll
all right wait what's the hat let's do a
little hat check real quick
very nice very nice he you also walked
in with the sunglasses i kind of wish
that you just left them on done the
whole uh the whole conversation was this
is a little bright in here
radio lights uh
let's get a miami update how's miami
been going it's good man i actually
haven't been here that much i've been uh
you know there's the big austin
conference so i've been away but uh yeah
it's you know it's great
uh miami tech week coming up yes
actually i think it's in april but
anyway that's coming up fun yeah
it's soon enough never too early you
know you've got to start preparing for
these things miami's uh this is when uh
everyone who's lived here for the last
year because they moved here they forgot
but starting november 1st through like
april or may that's when all of the like
snowbirds come
and so
if we look around at the restaurants
right now everything it's like oh like
there's you know they're kind of full
but now all of a sudden uh it gets real
crazy so when i moved here in january
there was way more people than there
have been over the last couple of months
and it's because all those people in new
york or where you know wherever else
they just come here for the uh for the
winter
and so uh
i think a lot of folks thought that the
new miami crowd was going to have left
during the summer but nobody really left
like you moved here then yeah i came
here during the depths of
yeah it was hot i remember when i saw
you the first time you're like dude it
is hot here
yeah but now everyone's gonna come back
it's gonna be fun i haven't experienced
the snowbird cross yet so i guess we'll
see
all right we're gonna talk mining first
you gave a
presentation at the texas blockchain
summit i think it was called that's
right um and
you uh
one gave like a state of the union on
mining then you explained texas and the
u.s energy grid and then you talked a
little bit about what makes texas so
special uh you don't know this but we
already pulled some of your slides and
we're just going to go through them oh
yeah
a couple of them uh the first slide that
we have are the easy ones i think we're
going to pull them up here in a second
and basically what uh
you highlight is just
how much electricity is actually used so
just maybe help us understand like it's
not nearly as much electricity as most
people think it is i mean it you know
it's all relative really you know and so
this uh is taken from a paper i wrote
with nydeg called bitcoin nut zero
and so we set out to sort of really
robustly quantify the electricity
consumption and also allow people to
sort of give them the tools to predict
the future electricity consumption
because the only people that have done
that historically have been like
wacky academics that get the numbers
wrong by like a factor of a thousand
so like there's this one paper from the
university of hawaii in 2018 that said
bitcoin was going to warm the earth by
two degrees
we appreciate your confidence in us but
we're not that i know they really like
really bitcoin maximalists to the core
right um and and their model was
premised on bitcoin having this per
transaction electricity cost which is
not how it works yep and also on bitcoin
transactions scaling up to hundreds and
hundreds of billions per year also not
really possible so we want to present
alternative models that actually make
sense okay so we have that first one
that uh if we pull it up here it's
simply just explaining that uh it's only
point two percent of all global
electricity generation and it's point
zero four percent of global primary
energy consumption what's the difference
between global primary energy
consumption and global electricity
generation so the world produces a lot
more energy than it does electricity
because there are non-electric sources
of energy like
uh combusting fuels for transport uh and
uh you know heating stoves yep that you
might be burning firewood or coal or
something like that
and so the amount of energy we produce
actually outstrips electricity so i
don't know you know it's sort of up to
you what you want to compare it to
whether you want to compare it to the
electricity that's produced on grid or
like the total you know energy this
world is producing which is a lot uh but
either way it's it you know
i i think it's relatively minimal for
you know a monetary system that stores
you know trillion dollars as of today
and settles
you know tens of billions of dollars a
day
so really it's small regardless it just
depends what you want to compare it to
and i don't think the country level
comparisons make any sense because most
of the countries bitcoin is typically
compared to
are like small like pretty agrarian
countries that have like exported their
industrial sector to places like china
and so given that we live in a
globalized economy
no one country if you look within their
geographic borders the like emissions
factor of their gdp a lot of that can be
externalized like industrial centers
like china right so
what you should be doing is just looking
at the industrial impact of like whole
industries and so that's another thing
we did in the paper is we compared
bitcoin to
certain industries certain sources of
load
certain metal extraction so we found
that it was kind of in the same universe
as zinc
we have that slide next slide yeah look
at this yeah i think we got that one
prepared you know finally once anyone
ever protested over like the you know
electricity associated with the zinc
extraction somebody somewhere probably
once but that's it you know what stupid
question i'm sure someone's upset about
it
stop the zinc manufacturers i mean to be
clear zinc is a great metal like you
know supplementing zinc is like a good
idea in my opinion um but you know i
don't see anyone getting like
apoblectically upset about it um and
then of course bitcoin is actually
generally less than gold um kind of
probably less than copper the emissions
and then of course aluminum and steel
are like
massive uh but yeah so like it compares
with kind of like niche metal extraction
so it kind of is what it is okay if we
go to the next slide here
we have this idea that uh it's not
digital gold in your opinion digital
aluminum so explain this yeah so i don't
know if uh have you guys visited any of
the big bitcoin plants
no there's this so there's one in
rockdale texas which is a really big one
um and then there's this other one i
have a picture here is in messina new
york on the saint lawrence river upstate
new york it just it's hard to get to we
like charted a little plane to get there
um those are former
alcoa smelting plants and aluminum you
know has the highest embodied energy
in the refining of the product of any
metal so for whatever reason
smelting bauxite and turning it into
aluminum takes a ton of electricity and
so because of that you had the smelters
would actually go to locations with
really abundant energy so they would
kind of chase the energy and so that's
why you'd end up with plants in like
upstate new york and things like that
with abundant power
and aluminum ended up being this way to
export energy through the commodity and
now the amazing historical parallels the
bitcoin is kind of like that uh bitcoin
mines are now taking up resonance in
these old smelting plants
um and so you know i just really like
that historical parallel like aluminum
used to be this way to soak up excess
energy now bitcoin does that yeah and
bitcoin does it better
much more efficiently because bitcoin's
modular you can have one shipping
container with 500 asics out there on
the oil field you know soaking up excess
wasted gas
you can obviously do with hydro
you can you know and you can interrupt
the process which is very important
we'll get into that um so yeah it's just
as a synthetic metal basically it does
it in a sort of like highly efficient
you know highly granular way next slide
and then it's big like people don't
realize how big it is and actually i
think this number has been growing uh
pretty rapidly right in terms of how
much people are actually being paid to
secure the network right now it's bigger
than this already i made these slides uh
you know uh ten thousand dollars ago
yeah it's a big industry though for sure
so right now uh if i just look quickly
approximately 51.52 million dollars over
the last couple of days is the mining
reward that globally is being paid out
for those that don't under uh standard
or don't know what that means uh the
bitcoin block subsidy the thing that is
given to miners every 10 minutes or so
in exchange for them helping to secure
the network there's adds up to 900
bitcoin per day you take 900 bitcoin per
day and you multiply it by uh the price
and so over the last 24 hours that's
52.6 million dollars according to
casebitcoin.com um all right let's go to
the next slide
by the way your title today on the show
is the most violent man in bitcoin
that's apt i really need to live up to
that
do it when you leave here
don't be violent right now other than
with your words
all right so with this uh i've now seen
multiple differences in this chart we
don't have the other one but there's a
chart that just came out that shows that
the us took majority of the market share
in china has zero we can talk about why
maybe china doesn't have zero
but definitely u.s has gained a ton of
market share china has lost a ton i know
and my regret is that i gave this
presentation a week before the new
cambridge data dropped so i have the old
chart on here but yeah suffice to say
the us is 35 percent of the network
today according to cambridge china is
apparently zero not actually zero
um cambridge couldn't wait to wipe them
out
oh china is zero yeah you're out of here
um yes so china is not actually zero but
yeah uh as i was pointing out here look
bitcoin mining us is the number one
country in the world we knew this even
before the cambridge data dropped now we
know it for sure number one country in
the world for bitcoin mining that's a
good thing before the china ban of
miners in may i think it was what was
the split between the us and china do we
remember in terms of what the u.s market
share was at that time i mean it's on
here the historicals i mean the us was
single digits for a long time okay uh so
very very much non-material uh china
just dominated they had you know 70
percent you know market share and and
the us was for a long time under 10
percent okay today u.s has 35 which is
the most out of anyone so it doesn't
mean that the united states has majority
it just means that no other country has
more than the united states u.s at 35
now the two things that you call out
here that i think is really interesting
one is the new asic deliveries and what
i want you to explain is uh i don't
think people understand the lead time
for the machines and how basically when
somebody makes an order
you know where those machines are going
and so you can start to forecast out a
little bit of where hash rate's going to
come online you know three four six
months whatever it takes for them to
actually plug the machines in yeah so
knowing a little bit about what the
miners are doing you can forecast the
hash rate of the bitcoin network in 12
months time and you can forecast where
mining will occur because you the miners
like to
you know announce that they've bought x
many units and that's promotional for
them so you just have to stitch all
those little pieces of data together and
you get a sense for where the where the
bitcoin network will be
in 12 24 months time obviously there's
some uncertainty in there so basically
um you know a lot of the i think the
best projections i've seen have the
bitcoin network being at 300 extra
hashes by the end of next year by the
end of next year and right now we're at
like what 150
yeah so doubling at least north of 300.
if you looked at where the you know new
machines were going they were all been
bought by u.s buyers and a lot of the
buyers are public companies so they're
providing those disclosures on ongoing
basis we also know what installations
they're building terms and megawatts so
we can get a pretty good sense of where
you know the industry is going to be in
a year's time uh and it you know it's
the build-out is happening in the us
where are they buying most of the
machines from is it still bit main or
are there other players that are now big
suppliers bitmain and what's minor micro
bt are the two big ones okay and of
those neither one are based in the
united states do we have concerns that
there is no actual like fabrication done
in the united states for the machines
yeah i think that's a concern um the
foundries are in i want to say korea and
taiwan obviously that's a big
geopolitical question if taiwan is going
to stay independent uh there is a
foundry being built by tsmc in austin i
believe uh and so they're trying to
diversify away i think they understand
the writings on the wall with taiwan
they want to kind of ship a lot of that
over it's going to take a while though
yeah and i guess part of this is if you
can get a fabrication facility built in
the united states you can one serve us
customers there's all kinds of kinds of
logistics uh they get solved there uh
but really it's probably the
geopolitical risk that they're solving
for yeah i mean there's a lot more
important things than not than making
bitcoin chips um you know like gpus i
mean it just like it's a critical
industry um the us just doesn't have a
homegrown one right now okay let's go to
the next slide
this is uh the united states and in
texas now
i'll let you defend yourself but i don't
want you pandering to texas because
you're not in texas anymore
if you were given this presentation at
the texas blockchain summit i'm assuming
that they were expecting you to say nice
things about taxes
explain why texas is so interesting well
yeah this is a texas that was the topic
they asked me to talk about so i wasn't
going to talk about bitcoin mining in
florida
[Laughter]
there isn't a lot when i saw this i
literally uh i saw somebody responded
online and they were like oh damn texas
is going to be huge i was like well yes
but this is also a texas-specific
conference look let's not write miami
and florida off we can still win this
okay we have currently approximately
zero amount of mining here in the great
state of florida and texas has a lot
they have a huge amount i mean i think
it's probably close to one gigawatt uh
keep in mind the whole bitcoin network
is uh approximately 10 gigawatts of
power so one tenth of the entire network
is in texas right now now that might be
an aggressive assumption but there's a
huge amount of build-out happening in
texas right now in particular west texas
where there's an enormous amount of
renewables and like the amount of
renewables that are coming onto the grid
in the coming years in texas is
unbelievable i mean unbelievable uh the
the texas grid i think is around 80
gigawatts uh ercot
and uh you're looking at you know maybe
20 30 gigawatts of of wind and solar uh
just in the next two years you think
that 25 to let's call it 40
of the texas grid is going to be used
for bitcoin mining oh no or is this net
new edition those are new renewables um
my projection is like two to three gigs
uh for bitcoin mining in texas by the
end of next year got it which i think is
is actually reasonably conservative
based on what's happening but yeah i
mean so that would be you know five-ish
percent of the grid maybe wow that's
still a lot it's helpful though it's
it's you know it's a very interesting
source of load uh it's a very kind of
unique and different source of load so
there's you know there's nuances there
okay all right let's go to the next one
i feel like we're playing a game of like
what's next because i forget what we put
in here okay all right so it's becoming
the
heartland of u.s mining let's go to
maybe the next one
and then this is how they're
aggressively expanding now most of this
is coming from publicly traded
uh disclosures yeah a lot of these are
public companies not all of them are
block streams not public
but yeah core size about to go public
will spack probably the biggest they'll
be the biggest publicly traded miner in
the us uh riot is active in texas
they're you know pretty big
you know compute north is building down
there in texas i mean like there's just
a huge amount of activity in the us
right now
you know if you're using you know modern
hardware you're mining your coins at so
like five to ten thousand dollars right
now you sell the coin eight thousand
dollars so so you think that's the price
of sophisticated miners is five to ten
thousand dollars depending on the energy
cost and labor cost and what you bought
your machines at yeah but keep in mind
you have to depreciate the value of the
hardware i mean you have to include the
amortization of buying the s19s and
things like that um but yeah like just
on the pure
you know um i mean that doubles the
price of the bitcoin on you know
including every single thing you
possibly could and now you're mining at
20 25 000 you're still selling it at 58
000. yeah the the margins are obscene
for miners right now uh it's unreal and
you know the china crackdown created a
huge kind of surplus for the us miners
china gave a subsidy to u.s miners
because it was a big it's a single
market yeah you know it's not like some
commodities where they sell for
different prices like natural gas in the
us is much cheaper than natural gas in
japan
but bitcoin sells for a single global
price and so if one country bans the
mining activity that's a subsidy to the
miners elsewhere it's incredible so this
is really interesting to me what you're
explicitly talking about is that china
shut down mining in their country and
that kicked off i don't know let's say
90 to 95 percent of all the miners in
the country when they did that we saw
hatchery go down uh i think more than 50
percent is when it bottomed yeah uh and
they had to literally unplug their
machines move elsewhere we at that time
saw a bunch flow to the united states
also elsewhere but the united states was
definitely the biggest winner from that
when you get that drop in hash rate the
difficulty adjustment was pretty it was
i mean it was pretty breathtaking just
how quickly uh it recovered and was able
to kind of withstand what many people
would think
of a normal computer system could
potentially be fatal right if 50 to 70
of all of your computing power went
offline in pretty much a moment's notice
there's not many systems that are just
chilling right
and so the mining difficulty what did
that do to the profit margins of u.s
miners like how severe was the impact of
the profitability well it just made it
much easier to create a unit of bitcoin
i mean 50 easier um
and and so that drove up their margins
enormously and so
that was like a truly exogenous shock
like people weren't really expecting
that
uh and of course it resulted in the
destruction of property you know tens of
billions of dollars of chinese miners
because frankly not all of them could
get their monies out of the country yup
a lot of them are just sitting fallow in
warehouses in malaysia and places like
that so you know they weren't
necessarily as a cohort able to plug
them in elsewhere i mean you know many
like the capacity in the us is pretty
tight in terms of hosting capacity so
there just wasn't that much ability to
absorb
uh you know miners from sichuan
uh into the us yeah and so there was a
destruction of their property and that's
unfortunately the nature of living in a
you know command and control economy
where things can change like that yeah
uh but you know it benefited uh the us
miners enormously like a huge huge
amount
let's go to the next slide
uh so why texas is it just that hey they
love oil and gas and they've built it
out no i mean texas has some like pretty
unique features so the governor is is
pro bitcoin uh both senators are now pro
bitcoin uh so we learned uh ted cruz is
incredibly smart about this stuff um i
don't know how he gained so much
expertise in the energy grid but he did
and it was very impressive okay so hold
on before you go on from that most
people i think have this view of ted
cruz which we got a sense
during the infrastructure bill stuff he
started to say some stuff that people
were like wait a minute like i agree
with ted cruz like that's not what i
thought he would be his position then
this conference i read you transcribed
some of his uh um his comments
he sounds like he's actually more
informed than some people in the bitcoin
community like he was pretty legit do we
know where that came from i don't know
frankly i mean i haven't been in contact
with him to be clear uh but his
expertise his level of command of the
nature of ercot and the texan grid and
the specific interactions miners have
with the grid which i guess we can get
into
was like phd level
really and this guy has to have a
position on like hundreds of different
issues
so i'm like sitting there wondering like
wait how did he
like get to that the thing that most
people would say doesn't really matter
that much but obviously he thinks is a
really big thing for texas and the
energy group yeah i mean it's striking
that he's put so much time and effort
into like really deeply understanding
this like what's a demand response
program what's a controllable load
resource like how does the supply demand
balancing operate on a grid how do the
miners you know come into that he
understands all that stuff
um and so i was pretty shocked by that i
spent years trying to figure it out and
ted you know just like coasts to the
front of the pack
all right so deregulated grid with
real-time spot pricing it kind of walk
us through like why is texas so suitable
yeah so erica is actually pretty
capacious but you keep saying ercot
people don't know what that is sorry
ercot is shorthand for like the texas
grid basically um
they have a ton of access renewables um
and i have a few slides i don't know if
we're going to do the whole presentation
we're not just 30 slides
i uh so i pump faked you like we go to
like slide 13 and then i just skipped
like three other ones
this is an important one okay you see
that wind corridor going from west texas
north to up to canada yep that's the
best area in the us to
uh you know mine your wind power right
why because it's windy okay uh shocking
that that is that is an amazing insight
i know it's really key don't forget that
that comes that'll be on the test
um so then we have the southwest of uh
america has the best solar resources
okay and when in solar like you know the
capacity factor is in the the uptime is
like kind of low for both those
resources but in west texas you have
this conjugation of it's very windy and
it's very sunny and that means wow
amazing like suitability for renewables
that's why 30 percent of the texas grid
today is renewable and that's grown from
like five percent 10 years ago
uh and so the problem is you've got 35
gigawatts of renewable
uh presence on the texan grid and it's
all in the northwest corner of texas but
all the load all the demand for energies
and kind of the southeast yep austin
houston dallas and energy doesn't travel
that well that's the thing people don't
get about electricity you can't teleport
it you have to put it in these high
voltage transmission lines right
and they only have 12 gigawatts of high
voltage transmission lines from west
texas to the load centers so those are
full
and then what happens the rest of the
time and there's only five gigawatts of
load locally in west texas which is
mostly associated with oil extraction so
what do you do with the remaining like
15 gigs so time out for a second i just
want to uh
say this so that people at home
understand
or uh wind and solar they suck in most
places because you can't do it 100 of
the time not remotely close to 100 of
time 25 to 40 okay
in the west part of texas very
specifically it's hot and sunny and it's
windy so you basically can do wind and
solar much more than you can do other
places
but the problem is that the people who
need the electricity are far away yeah
in the other part of the state and so
the ability to transport it there you
basically can't put any more through
that transportation because it's already
full
and then we say well why don't you just
use it right there on site all of the
normal uses for electricity that's also
spoken for and so now you basically have
created all this additional
energy but you don't know what to do
with it and keep in mind they're going
to be doubling the quantity of renewable
energy produced mainly in west texas
in the coming years this is the part of
the conversation where like bitcoin
shows up with like a superman cape and
is like here to save the day because it
can do what i mean it can it can absorb
that excess of stranded energy um and
like if you don't use the energy it just
gets pumped into the ground you know um
and actually you see this if you look at
a map of prices in texas the left you
know the western half
is often negatively priced the energy
producers will pay people to take the
energy away from them
and the right half you know is where
it's actually expensive so bitcoin is
kind of this sponge which soaks up the
excess
and you know that's incredibly useful
for these renewable producers because
now they have a second buyer of energy
initially they just had one buyer which
was the grid and the grid would only buy
it on its own terms
now there's a second independent
you know uncorrelated buyer which means
they can monetize these assets at you
know interesting times and they have the
choice who they're going to sell to so
that makes the economics their core
business much much better
and so you know some people say like
okay well bitcoin is not an incentive to
build new renewables you know maybe
that's that's fine but like it's
certainly a way to monetize existing
renewables and make their payback cycles
much faster and that really matters in
the energy landscape and it feels like
uh we're just talking about renewables
and
there's persistent demand from bitcoin
which is a huge piece of this and that's
where you're getting into well sometimes
i actually want to sell to the bitcoin
network because i know what i'm going to
get paid there but also there may be a
spike in need on the energy grid or cot
and i may get paid more than i would
even make with bitcoin and so i may
offload but i now have choice and when i
have choice it allows me to better
optimize my business based on the
current factors absolutely and what's
more is the miners opt into these
programs where the grid operator tells
them hey you want you want to turn off
your machines for a little bit so that
all the power can go to households that
need it the most so when you have
scarcity on the grid the miners turn
themselves off they actually get paid to
do this
uh and so
they are not depriving anyone of energy
they are actually
uh monetizing the energy assets most of
the time and during an energy crisis or
period of scarcity they're off
and so all of that energy
goes to households in hospitals you know
to whatever run air conditioning
so you know that's a really important
thing there are formal programs on the
texas grid that miners are perfectly
suitable for and other industrial
centers of load or not because virtually
nothing else can turn itself off at
short notice like that bitcoin miners
can turn themselves down or off within
seconds
so they can deal with the interrupt
ability
uh aluminum smelting you know factory
can't or uh you know a grain processing
facility can't turn itself off uh you
know commercial real estate can't just
turn itself off like that so miners are
this unique flexible load that's really
suitable for a grid like that where if
the grid's really in high demand there's
energy scarcity they can just be off
okay let's go to the gas flare capture
uh if we keep going matt to uh next one
here
explain what gas flare capture is and
why this is so powerful for the miners
and also from an environment standpoint
so this is truly off-grid mining so in
the case of mitigating flared gas you're
actually just not on the grid at all and
so the way oil extraction works is
whenever you get oil out of the well it
comes up in a mixture of oil and gas
so
you're actually not just getting oil
you're getting oil and gas oil is the
thing you want gas is generally treated
as kind of a waste product and
oftentimes with a lot of these wells
you're not connected to pipelines so you
don't have a way to take the gas away
there's no economic use for it so what
they actually do is because methane is
pretty bad for the environment they
combust it which has the output of
carbon dioxide and the carbon dioxide is
what is released post combustion so
that's the flaring like you know if you
look at an image of like oil derricks
like you'll see the flares right
the flaring is like pretty inefficient
doesn't burn that well
uh some of the methane isn't combusted
so what the miners do instead is they
take this waste product natural gas they
put in a generator and they burn it in a
more complete combustion process and
they mine bitcoin with the with the
electricity um and so like that is a
dramatic improvement over the status quo
and so people look at this they don't
like it because you know they see miners
that are using natural gas but the thing
to understand is the natural gas was
going to be combusted anyway there was
no economic use for it on site there was
no way to get it to a market right it
just wasn't worth it natural gas is
pretty cheap in the us really really
cheap so it's not worth building a
pipeline infrastructure to take it away
and i guess the other last thing to note
is like when you do what's called
initial production on oil well so you
you sort of initially start it up
there's oftentimes like a six-month
burst of natural gas
and there typically wouldn't be the
ability to you know accommodate that gas
and get it to market so
the bitcoin miners in this case come in
take advantage of that and you know they
might leave in in six months time so
it's it's a remarkably like flexible
uh and you know potentially short-term
relationship
most of the companies i know that are
doing this are bitcoin mining companies
going to the gas flare companies the
companies are flaring gas
are we have we seen the reverse have we
seen any of those companies say hey why
don't we just become the experts and
like vertically integrate
yeah so um
i believe upstream data do not actually
do the mining themselves they create the
gensets and the units for energy
asset owners to mine themselves on a
proprietary basis
so
i think you'll see more of this too
frankly um i think we're going to see in
the next few months energy companies
actually
get into this space on a primary basis
as opposed to contracting out with
miners agreed uh and if we go to this
slide right here we're talking about the
gas flare carbon negative
this to me
puts us into the realm of uh bitcoin is
preventing climate change is it solving
climate change is it uh
having a hand in presenting a solution
or a potential solution like how do you
think about bitcoin gas fire capture and
then this whole climate change debate
and kind of effort that's underway i
mean it's certainly in the context of
the flare gas mitigation is making
climate change no worse okay so it's not
contributing more to the problem at a
minimum because the gas is flared
regardless that's just a byproduct of
hydrocarbon extraction and we still need
oil for cars and airplanes and boats and
things like that so we're not going to
be able to wean ourselves off of that
anytime soon so during this transition
phase where we still use hydrocarbons
you know there's going to be this
externality of natural gas that's
unquestionable
the miners can deal with it in a way
that has a lighter climate impact than
the default way which is flaring or
venting frankly
and and if you're flaring on a windy day
most of it's vented anyway so
by controlling the reaction by coming
and piping the oil into a generator
uh and you know combusting in a more
controlled way you're mitigating the
emissions that's the chart i have here
with crusoe energy
uh and so you know that's that's a net
improvement for sure i'm gonna let my
brothers ask questions about mining in a
second but uh if you have to think about
how important this is for the united
states moving forward what we see going
on in texas obviously is pretty
impactful is this something where other
states and cities will start to
replicate this in a material way or is
it specific to that environment because
texas has the renewables it has the the
kind of energy grid aspects that we've
been talking about no i mean i think
we're going to see it being relevant for
nuclear we're already seeing nuclear
providers partnering up with bitcoin
miners because again just having an
uncorrelated buyer improves your core
economics
and you know nuclear runs all the time
but the grid demand is like a sine wave
right and so at night you know energy
might be really cheaply priced and so
what if you could monetize your nuclear
output at night by selling the bitcoin
instead of selling to the grid
and you know that would improve your
economics and improve your payback
periods you know that might give you a
better incentive to build more nuclear
so
uh it goes far beyond just wind and
solar
we know bitcoin is mined with hydro as
well
but yeah it's a pressure it's an
economic pressure on the grid which i
think uh you know liberates some of
these like stranded or underutilized
assets
what questions you guys got about
bitcoin mining mining uh just where it's
going to go right like the u.s overtook
and and kind of has the largest
percentage now um like how do you think
this trends over time is it good for us
to have a large percentage should it get
larger should it stay kind of relative
to where it is now like say five ten
years from now where do you think it
should be
so i think um
the middle east is going to get more
important in bitcoin mining because they
actually have a ton of flared gas which
is a you know waste resource um and so
it's one way to turn your natural
resources into like a sovereign wealth
asset right and so i think we're going
to see that i wouldn't be surprised to
see uae or the saudis uh start to mine
and they don't really have much of a
footprint today
if we got over 50 percent
you know some people are going to start
to worry they're going to say oh well
the us is too big the us could
commandeer all the miners and you know
change something about bitcoin
i'm not really as worried about that
china i was a bit worried i mean china
is a one-party state it's authoritarian
in the us we have a rule of law and we
also you know segment we have local
governance like the states have some
power
and energy policies made at the state
level so the us government would not
have the legal ability or really the
authority to you know
commandeer everyone's miners and then
initiate some sort of government driven
hard fork it's just not possible
um so you know i i do expect the us to
keep growing because we have the
cheapest cost of capital we you know the
us is something like 25 of the world's
gdp but 40 of the world's publicly
traded equity so we punch above our
weight when it comes to capital markets
and all these miners go public and then
they subsidize themselves by effectively
issuing stock to the public markets and
so far the markets have accepted that so
as long as the miners in the us are able
to do that
um they're going to keep growing they're
going to keep growing their footprint
and you know the us is an energy-rich
country so um we're going to keep you
know keep growing our our share of the
mining network
john what do you got i'm glad you
brought up all these issues they're uh
they're crazy i'm curious how does an
individual like myself i own no mining
equipment how do i get involved in this
how can i make money off of uh
off this mining going on in texas and
around the united states i think we
should plug one in in the studio
we could do that so the problem is we
might have to do in the other room
because they're very loud they sound
like a hornet's nest i don't know if you
guys have ever visited you gotta use
some like earpro because
they are very very loud and they get hot
too so actually maybe we reconsider that
hole
we'll put it in another part of the
building so that we don't have to deal
with it or hear it or see it but we can
get the money from it john but there are
uh hosted mining providers that can give
you an allocated unit at a host
i think compass mining is probably the
best known one um and so like you can
absolutely start mining today as a
regular individual if you wanted can i
get involved in the texas situation at
all
probably i mean uh i'm sure there's host
there's hosting in texas and i think i
read a while ago
like compass is demand picked up a lot
right over the last
six or 12 months they've had a
blockbuster year turns out everybody
wants to mine themselves yeah i think
it's a good feeling
that's cool are you you want to go to
texas john no we should go check out a
facility we'll send show from there you
guys should visit rockdale right that's
like the biggest facility in texas i
think they let us film a show from there
yeah yeah
loud but you weren't allowed but i'll
set it up
joe what'd you say that's fine yeah you
might have to ask them to turn off a
couple hundred do you want to be part of
our union by the way we unionized it
again no get out of here yeah yeah we're
recruiting he's like oh yeah i missed
the first part of the show yeah no we
unionized john and i and we're
recruiting so if you want in you're in
i'm in i'm in there we go uh they're mad
because i told them i was gonna bust
their union and now they're recruiting
for they want higher pay better medical
care
see i don't even get paid
we're going to work that in you're going
to be part of these we're going to
change that nick we can check summoned
here like on short notice
this was the longest notice i've ever
given you it's like two days i know it
was great
power numbers
all right let's talk inflation uh the
official numbers came in 5.4 percent
core is at four percent uh i don't think
anyone believes the real the official
numbers and then on top of that uh they
keep saying it's transitory you and i
have talked in the past
in
march april may june july august and
probably into september of last year
they kept saying don't worry about
inflation we're not worried about
inflation inflation's not coming etc
maybe somewhere in the like august
september october november december time
frame they started to say well
maybe there might be inflation but we're
still not worried about it then like in
q1 it turned into like oh there's gonna
be a little bit of inflation but it's
gonna be transitory actually our goal is
to run hot
for a couple of months
and then we got five percent cpi and
it's been four months of cpi above five
percent that the last time that happened
was in the 08 crisis uh before that was
in the mid 1990s what's your read on the
inflation that we have
should we be worried or does this fit in
like the transitory camp i mean we
should definitely be worried and to be
clear like transitory doesn't mean your
purchasing power is going to go back to
what it was correct if if we're truly
transitory we'd have deflation to
compensate for the burst of inflation we
will never have compensatory deflation
we did in the 1800s if you had an
inflationary period you would actually
then have a peer to sustained deflation
healthy deflation that was actually
really so you had a 100 year period
where prices started and ended the same
in the us
that's never going to happen in the
modern fiat economy it's just that the
rate of you losing purchasing power is
accelerating that's what they mean by
transitory it's not very comforting
um
yeah i mean obviously they're trying to
massage the narrative and uh you know
the fed kind of tends to believe that
expectations drive inflation so consumer
and employer expectations are key
drivers of inflation that's sort of the
orthodox view and so that's why they
expend so much effort giving speeches
all the time trying to manage our
expectations
and if we uh you know poke a hole in the
narrative we're actually altering
expectations and thus making inflation
more likely so that's why they are
constantly in the press like trying to
say you know talk us down be like no no
you know don't worry about it it's uh
it's gonna you know abate uh but i don't
think it will i mean look we're on the
cusp of a bit of a global energy crisis
there's a lot of headlines
about energy scarcity uh if you have
scarce energy prices go up and energy is
the key input into everything so
you know fundamentally energy is like
the the main sort of unit of account if
the world is short on energy
everything is impacted so
notwithstanding you know the supply
uh the supply side issues which all the
commentators are now blaming for
inflation um we've embarked on this
energy policy whereby
uh you know fracking has been banned in
much of the world uh leading to much
more structurally more expensive natural
gas
um you know for for better for worse you
know we can debate the merits of the
policy but we're gonna have an energy
shortage situation uh esg mandates and
attacking uh you know the the oil majors
um you know the way exxon's been
attacked royal dutch shell has been
attacked through the corporate
governance lens that just means that the
world is less adept at producing actual
effective energy than it was kind of ten
years ago so that's going to you know
continually cause pressure
um
yeah and there's there's a lot more to
cover i mean there's the base effects
thing that we can talk about um so let's
let's do base effects first and then i
want to talk about like the
normalization of it in the public
conversation but the base effect
argument was basically hey we had a
global pandemic and everyone was ordered
to go sit inside their home of course
everything comes down and so yes we will
see a high rate of change over a
12-month period but that's simply
because uh we were coming off of that
lower base
i think you believe that now well we're
back to where we were before the
pandemic from a base effects standpoint
12 months ago but we saw a really high
rate of inflation yeah so we had
disinflation during the early days of
the pandemic because demand dropped off
a cliff and so the rate of
yeah so effectively um
we didn't have deflation but we had
disinflation so inflation was low and
then there were all these articles
written in sort of april 2021 saying
well actually 12 months ago because we
had disinflation that's going to make
inflation look really high today but
don't worry about it that's just a
mathematical quirk that's because you're
looking at year-over-year data and a
year ago the inflation rate was really
low which makes today look really high
however the base effects in my view
expired in july of this year so that's
no longer a plausible explanation lo and
behold we're still running really really
hot
so this whole story that was cooked up
for us about why inflation looks hot you
know all these economists like
like explaining to us oh yeah this is
just cause like you suck at interpreting
the data they were wrong okay and
they're not acknowledging that now like
inflation you know now they've pivoted
to saying okay no there's supply chain
reasons but what are they not mentioning
when they talk about the supply chain
it's like just this abstract thing why
is the supply chain stressed because the
government printed trillions and
trillions of dollars and handed it out
directly to households for them to go on
a spending spree right during the depths
of the pandemic and they started buying
tons of consumer electronics and
everything else and so the supply chain
became taxed because of that injection
of cash right and so like that is a big
part of the explanation
you know because consumers change their
spending patterns because all of a
sudden they had thousands and thousands
of dollars just deposited in their bank
account from the government so you know
that is the government injection of cash
into the economy causing inflationary
effects is just processed through the
lens of the supply chain but it's still
ultimately inflationary
i don't think i've ever heard
a
monetary policy related position so
central banker
one of somebody from the treasury um
even i think globally but definitely the
united states i don't think i've heard a
single one of them say that the monetary
policy had an impact on the inflation of
course not i mean i don't think i've
heard one time somebody say that and you
know it's the same thing during weimar
they steadfastly refuse to acknowledge
that the rate of money issuance might
have an effect on inflation so they
refuse to admit that the quantity of
money might affect the price of money
that's every government going through an
inflationary episode ever but you know i
i believe that central bankers actually
do understand what's going on i do
believe that and i believe that uh you
know congress understands as well it's
just right now inflation is actually
politically convenient that's what
doesn't get talked about because we have
such a high debt load as a country the
only way to reduce our debt to gdp
barring some sort of productivity
miracle where our gdp grows
you know through some exogenous shock
maybe we discover nuclear fusion or
something
barring that the only way we're going to
reset our debt to gdp level and get our
debt service down
is through inflation and so we're going
to have a soft default so inflation is
actually really politically convenient
so when policymakers say they want to
inhibit inflation they want to ratchet
it down don't believe them because it's
politically necessary now
to to actually have an inflationary
burst which was the exact same thing we
had in the 1940s after the wartime
expenditure so when that occurs we're at
5.4 percent you know give or take over
the last couple of months do we go
higher from here do we stay at around
five percent or do you think that we
come back down to like a two percent
let's say uh next
year or so so the thing about inflation
is that it's not just a structurally
high rate of inflation it's just that
the
loss of purchasing power is also
volatile so if you look at other
inflation error episodes whether it's
the 40s the 70s it's very volatile and
that's actually the worst part because
it means businesses cannot project what
what resources they're going to need a
year from now or two years from now and
we saw this in the construction industry
when like the lumber prices all exploded
literally people just said hey we're not
agreeing to build anything because we
know that there's a three to six month
lead time and we can't project what the
price of lumber is going to be and
therefore we can't tell you what the
house is going to cost because we may be
underwater or we may
make a bunch of money but that
uncertainty doesn't allow us to do it
you're not talking it's not just one
specific commodity and one industry
you're saying across an entire economy
that's true it's the allocation of
resources in the economy so that's why
big corners talk about time preference
there's a very real connection to
inflation and time preference as
inflation cranks up you lose the ability
to claim for the future a great example
of this would be venezuela you can't get
a mortgage right in venezuela because
the thing would be denominated in
uh bolivars it's completely impossible
to know would it be worth 30 years from
now
uh and so you can't engage in sort of
long-term
uh you know acquisition of capital
assets
uh you can't really debt doesn't work
right so you know obviously less extreme
version of that now
it's hard to know what reason what your
cost of capital is going to be
um you know if if you're in an
inflationary burst or you don't really
know what the rate of change of
purchasing power is going to be 12 24
months from now and so your time horizon
comes in
and that's why you know
a lot of people connected to
you know the ability to build longer
term projects when we were on the gold
standard which was because
the money supply growth was always sort
of one to two percent and interest rates
were generally pretty stable um whereas
now
we have structural instability
yeah when you think about what this does
to an individual we know that 45 of
americans have no investable assets 55
percent have some assets but really it's
the top you know one maybe 10 percent
that are kind of benefiting from this is
it as simple as hey people should just
go invest uh regardless of the market
and they're going to end up benefiting
or are there other things that you think
folks who understand what's happening
are doing to protect themselves whether
it's changing their consumer purchase
behavior or something else the problem
is you do have to change your behavior
when faced with inflation because it
affects everything it actually affects
equities too
periods of rising inflation very
negative for equity prices by the way um
so
you know if you look at the the you know
the the difference or how they trade
during different epics of disinflation
versus high inflation the problem is
you've just spent an increasing amount
of your time being tactical and
determining your asset allocation of
course it's possible to escape
inflationary bursts with your assets
intact uh you know if you go to
commodities or uh you know precious
metals or things like that
but it's just a lot of work right it's a
drag
and normal folks should not be
apportioning too much of their mental
energy to like determining how to you
know allocate their assets right they
would just love to be able to save
normally and just live their lives but
the problem is you get forced
into becoming speculator right and
that's why we see with all these
inflationary episodes speculative surges
every single one you see a speculative
surge and so regular folks have to start
thinking okay well do i want to own big
tech here do i want cyclicals am i going
to own you know currency am i going to
hold cash i can't hold cash you know
like what am i going to hold now and
just becomes this whole thing
and so you know that's one of the worst
things about high inflation is that it
just if it you know forces everyone to
question the value of their savings and
you know plow into you know potentially
higher yield assets yeah and
how does it end
right is it that inflation just
naturally kind of tapers off and yes we
don't get a return back to uh normal
prices so chipotle puts their menu
prices up four percent we're not going
back but we just stopped the rate of
change going up so aggressively and so
it goes back to kind of like a two
percent rate of change or is there have
to be some sort of external um you know
force is it a policy decision change
like what drives the kind of end if you
will of higher inflation i mean
inflation ended in the 70s when
the 80s when paul volcker cranked up
interest rates to like 20 percent and
that's called the volcker shock and that
sent the economy into a very steep
recession
um but so the government had to do that
to prove that you know they could take
short-term pain and
effectively destroy
some of the quantity of money certainly
inhibit the rate of growth of money by
cranking up interest rates because when
you increase interest rates lending you
know declines
and so that was like their nuclear
weapon against the sustained high
inflation that we saw in the 70s was the
willingness to take that medicine
now what would paul volcker do if he was
in charge of the fed today he would quit
he would resign because he cannot raise
interest rates because our debt to gdp
is so much higher when he did the
volcker shock in the 80s debt to gdp was
like 30 percent but today it's like 120
130 percent so if you raise interest
rates to that level today the government
would default the corporate sector would
default no one can stand debt becoming
expensive like that
and so
i think really the only way this ends is
after a sustained
long period
of very low interest rates and high
inflation um you know
we we ratchet down
the the size of the debt generally
speaking
uh and then we can sort of get to a new
equilibrium but it's going to be a
damaging and difficult sort of couple
decades probably um and if if you look
at what happened in the 40s if you held
government debt
you know you held dollars you lost in
real terms uh and so that's sort of what
has to happen here but the question is
like how does a central bank regain
credibility after they've lost it
because an inflation is a loss of
credibility for the central bank
um i don't know if they're ever gonna
get their credibility back
i tend to think that's gonna be hard
right i don't know if we know yet will
they get it back or will they not but
it's definitely in question
um what do you think about the bitcoin
etf is it likely to get approved not get
approved do you think it matters
well the etf that gensler has signaled
he wants would be the futures-based etf
which would be an inferior product in my
mind
you know might have an additional 10
drag in there because the cost of
rolling futures
um spot etfs work fine we've seen them
work in canada we see them work in
europe there's nothing unexpected or
complicated about them you're just
literally holding bitcoin then you have
daily liquidity and it equilibrates so
it tracks the price really closely a
futures-based etf is an inferior product
it's just less efficient right
but that looks like what we're going to
get i wouldn't be surprised i think the
first deadline is the 18th
of this month
and there's a whole bunch of pending
applications i think we probably will
get
a futures-based etf and i think we're
going to continue to be stonewalled on
the spot etf side which is what we all
really want and that would be the
blockbuster product that would see
hundreds of billions in inflows that
would have more inflows than gld did
within its first week uh which i think
was the hottest edf launch ever so
so we're on the 14th now so monday
basically is when the they have to give
an answer on the futures can they kick
the can down the road or do they have to
make a decision um that's a great
question i think that might have to be a
like a resubmit your application type
thing yeah if they it's a reject or
accept it's not uh hey we postpone our
decision yeah i mean they've had uh like
six months already to kind of say
something about it so okay uh so if you
had to guess now you think it gets
approved was the futures yeah and it's
just you know ultimately not a very
compelling product you might see a
couple billion in inflows but uh that's
just not what investors deserve i mean
and the weird thing is you're allowed to
have like a 4x inverse
levered
you know natural gas tracking etf that
like mathematically will decline by
95 a year
um and that's permissible
and a spot etf tracking one of the
largest commodity markets in the world
traded in hundreds of jurisdictions very
sophisticated market infrastructure is
not allowed why do you think that is
politically i'm certain at this point i
mean
like most most of you like etf analysts
at bloomberg will say the same thing
that there's a political gating factor
for the etf uh which is simply that uh
you know they they don't want bitcoin to
gain uh the sort of authority and the
blessing of the sec
um because like all of the challenges
the sec has made to
the sponsors of those etfs have been met
there's no question about that um and if
you look at
the standards being applied to other
commodity markets where price
manipulation does happen i mean hell the
biggest market in the world uh libor was
manipulated right but that doesn't mean
you can't have financial products
tracking interest rates right uh silver
had an infamous episode of price fixing
that doesn't mean there isn't a silver
etf right
so
writing off bitcoin by saying oh we
don't like the market structure you know
there's episodes of manipulation that
doesn't make sense it's not the standard
uh so they're applying some sort of
uneven standard bitcoin versus all other
commodities
what do you think happens to the bitcoin
price by the end of the year we're at 58
000 or so if the etf gets approved
it takes off if it doesn't get approved
it doesn't or like what's your thought
process on like end of year price of
bitcoin well i was i earlier this year i
thought well we're going to see whether
the base effect story plays out by the
fall
we're going to see whether the
transitory story is real
i think it's become clear now that
the
whole developed world not just the us is
engineering kind of a soft default of
their currencies they are in synchrony
devaluing them all together and it's
kind of like swimming downstream you
know like no one currency is going to
swim against the current so they won't
appreciate relative to the others
they're all going to devalue the same
rate or you know roughly the same rate
so people won't necessarily notice it if
you're looking at dxy the dollar index
but yeah i mean you'll notice it if you
go to the gas station or you know buy a
stake
and so i think there is this realization
setting in
oh wow like the government is going to
hold interest rates down and they're
going to crank up inflation and if
they're going to engineer soft default
how tactically do i an asset allocator
deal with that i don't want to hold
treasuries i probably don't actually
want to hold equities
because they generally do bad during
periods of rising inflation what am i
looking at and you know some of those
allocators looking at bitcoin
how many how much of the
portfolio do you think they can put it
right because i always go to if you
reach that conclusion then the natural
end state is i have to get allocated but
if i'm buying it because i'm scared of
inflation i think inflation's going to
continue i think it's going to be
persistently higher
and i really don't have that many other
places to put it then the question
almost becomes not should i do this it's
how much can i do it within my uh kind
of investment mandate right like what's
the upper bound and so is that like a
two percent a five percent a ten can
people do twenty percent like what do
you see is kind of that upper bound i
mean i it just depends on like the
nature of the allocator and you know you
talk to institutions all the time like i
would say family offices can do like a
really material amount uh we see like
you know some degen family offices out
there for sure they just have full
discretion um you know pension funds
i've generally found are like less
willing to consider it because sometimes
they don't even have a commodities
allocation
um hedge funds of course can kind of do
whatever they want within their mandate
um yeah i'd be interested to see
sovereign wealths
and i think you know maybe this will be
the year or next year without that you
know they start to dip their toes in
whether indirectly through mining
expect that or directly through exposure
um so it really just depends on sort of
the nature of the allocator yeah and if
they do start to allocate similar to
what we saw in october november uh
december of 2020 into the q1 it felt
like people
who started to open their eyes to
inflation we saw paul tutor jones come
out publicly and say hey you know i want
to own the fastest horse etc they all
kind of front ran the inflation right we
didn't get the five percent prince until
the summer but they had all pretty much
allocated to the asset it was a asset
that at the time had 80 to 90 percent of
the circulating supply was held by
long-term holders a bunch of new demand
shows up price exploded upwards it feels
like now we back our from a market
structure standpoint 85 of bitcoin
hasn't moved in 90 days um and so that
component of like the supply constraint
is back uh if demand kind of gets a
second leg here do you expect there to
be like a very material uh kind of price
increase again or is this something
where we're more in this like grinding
up and you'll just kind of every day get
more and more people capitulating in
buying
yeah so like on the one hand you know it
seems similar in some ways to the double
bubble in 2013 where the second leg up
was completely explosive
um
on the other hand you know you have to
think about who owns bitcoin and so
there's a lot of firms that own bitcoin
as part of a target allocation
and as bitcoin appreciates
they rebalance
and so that actually eliminates some of
the volatility on both the downside and
the upside volatility
you know because you see this sort of
just
targeted selling as bitcoin into the
rally
and also dip buying activity because if
you want a five percent target
allocation uh you have to be you know
strategic like that so i think that will
attenuate some of the volatility um all
that said i'm very optimistic about
where bitcoin is i mean ultimately
you know i think the modern central
banks have lost their authority and you
know that even more so than inflation
uh is the main thing that's going to
drive people into the asset class yeah i
tend to uh tend to think that's right
about the regulatory regime in the u.s
so we've got the sec with bitcoin it's a
weird thing because they've said it's
not a security which kind of de-teeths i
think a lot of the regulatory concerns
at the same time all of the corporations
and some individuals that support
bitcoin specifically also support other
assets and so they have regulatory
pressures uh that might not be directly
because of bitcoin but because of the
industry is that a concern in terms of
like serving as like a headwind for
bitcoin uh or do you think that some of
that other stuff it'll kind of get a
bifurcation or like a decoupling and
bitcoin will uh kind of be blessed in
terms of that'll continue on but some of
this other stuff may get caught up i
mean bitcoin is definitely present in
you know industry sectors like d5 like
this definitely bitcoin that circulates
there uh generally speaking i think
would be largely insulated from a
crackdown on
you know on your defies that where the
sec has kind of
uh suggested they would really go after
it
there's you know strong regulatory
clarity as to what bitcoin is it's kind
of considered a commodity depending on
the regulator property
so there's no questions there
it's pretty institutionalized
so i mean you know the worst that could
happen is the occ
uh you know puts us a step back says
banks can't touch bitcoin which you know
i kind of expect to happen
but you know regardless like the sec
they have a real big bark and the
question is like how big will the bite
be
and it appears to me that they'll need
fundamentally more resources to actually
fulfill their ambitions uh that they're
openly stating
to crack down on the long tail because
you're you're basically making the
argument that uh if there's thousands of
uh various coins that are out there and
they're saying hey you're not allowed to
do this at some point it's like
jaywalking right like you're allowed to
jaywalk but can we actually stop
everybody no
so in some weird way it's almost
decriminized by lack of enforcement and
so they have to pick their spots in
terms of where they do it based on the
resource they have today well that's
like certainly
the dominant view i would say is that
there's kind of like a ddos on their
ability you know there's just so much
out there it's hard for them to tackle
things um i think they could go after
choke points uh with the exchanges
probably being
primary and then maybe even the
operators of some of these d5 protocols
they could probably try to find a way to
coerce them so i think they probably do
have the ability to find leverage in
their enforcement
um but regardless
you know they will need more resources
to do that
and that might require congress you know
increasing their budget or something
like that so
a lot of this i think does come down to
congress and their ability to act
the midterms are coming up i don't know
if we're going to have a fully blue
uh government after the midterms you
know it could be split so i think it's
quite possible we got gridlock which
inhibits a lot of the government's plans
to sort of tackle the crypto industry
what's fascinating to me is uh we have
senator lummus we have congressman
davidson we've now have ted cruz kind of
raising his hand and saying hey i'm
really educated on this stuff
there's a number of other
congressmen or senators who
appear to be either one very educated on
this stuff or two
are
being supportive and kind of saying hey
look we need this in the united states
but there's also a lot that aren't right
and we've seen everyone from the brad
shermans of the world etc who are even
elizabeth warren they're just outright
against it and they would love to see
the industry go away
is that just politics as normal or do
you think that there is uh competing
agendas like i i read a lot online and
people are like oh you know the uh brad
sherman's biggest donors are the credit
card companies and i'm like
maybe or like are they really that smart
like it like is there really this big
kind of conspiracy or is it literally
just no some people are open-minded
about innovation other people aren't and
so that's where they kind of fall on the
line yeah what's funny is i think the
banks are gonna eventually be big
supporters of bitcoin uh because i agree
you know it ends up bringing more
vibrancy to their business model there's
more things they can do
you know they're you know they'd like to
get active in the industry it's like an
interesting way to earn new sources of
revenue so
um i don't think the bank lobby would
really ultimately be that hostile to the
industry
i think where the where the split
actually does fall is in terms of the
ideology of how much authority and
insight the government should have into
our transactions and so we kind of see a
split developing between people that
think
well maybe like you know the bank
secrecy act was an overreach and maybe
we ended up with a structurally
unconstitutional level of surveillance
that's obviously my stance and so you
know those folks tend to be more
sympathetic bitcoin and then the
opposing camp is actually we should use
finance to
project political
ambitions into the economy at large so
use financial rails to actually impose
kind of government mandates
and there's a whole other camp that
believes that they tend to be hostile to
bitcoin because bitcoin gives you
transactional freedom and some measure
of privacy and they tend to be in favor
of a cbdc
and so that is kind of the split that i
see which is a genuine and non-contrived
ideological divide
uh and i i don't see anyone on the cbd
side cbdc side
ever
you know crossing over to bitcoin
regardless of how well we explain it to
them yeah
you know we talked yesterday about uh
the janet yellen interview on cbs
news and uh they asked you know about
peeking into americans uh
um pocketbooks she's like that's not
what we're trying to do here whatever
and the first thing that i went to was
look again right now they have to ask
they either have to change the policies
right and get like regulation here or uh
they have to use the courts and so there
is some checks and balances that are in
place now again you could say that it's
kind of like that uh that one video
where the guy is uh outside of the
security guard he basically is like not
really checking folks right like there's
an element of like you just go to the
court like hey we think they're doing
bad things right like okay here here you
go get their financial information um
but at least in theory there is
something with the central bank digital
currency like it's over yeah right and
now it's all sudden you operate on my
system i can see everything and to me
that is uh in some weird way an argument
that is very pro bitcoin from a sense of
uh once you digitize all the currencies
there's no technology competition uh
value is free to flow with very little
friction or cost to kind of the soundest
money and so you know if i have a good
currency uh inside of the american
economy in the us dollar and i want to
go to mexico to the peso it's really
hard with the switching cost if i could
just do that on my phone now all of a
sudden where's the competition go to
just like a monetary policy competition
and i think we're all pretty much in
agreement that like bitcoin is different
now is it right or wrong we'll find out
in the market but uh because it is
different the switching cost goes down
by digitizing the other currencies
everyone gets digital wallets like now
you're going to just see more capital
flow in some weird ways like that
savings technology whereas right now the
friction is really high is that yeah
sound right i buy that yeah i mean the
other thing is i think the growth and
existence of a cbdc would more strongly
motivate people to seek out alternatives
because at that point they're realizing
oh we have a borderline social credit
system in this country because it's not
like the us government doesn't have a
history of using banks and bank policy
to control what regular people can do
there is a well-known operation called
operation chokepoint where the fdic and
the doj
instructed banks to instruct payment
processors not to service certain
industries
and you know it doesn't really matter
what industries they were frankly many
of them were completely legal industries
so you know we've seen through this kind
of uh you know kind of really um
indirect
non-uh disclosed uh untransparent
approach we've seen uh government trying
to make policy through the bank sector
now if they have the direct ability to
do that with a cbdc
uh it would just give them a huge amount
of control over who can make money and
how
uh and so i think that'll cause a lot of
people to do a bit of soul searching
realize okay do i want this system or do
i want like this other system that
actually seems more american yeah oh i
know let's not go down that path because
i completely agree i can spend hours
talking to you guys get any other
questions
i'm all good people in the chat also
continue to say uh the most violent man
in bitcoin so you're uh you're living up
to your uh i got to do something about
it
you got some more street cred for
joining the union too yeah oh yeah dude
[ __ ] that you already forgot oh yeah no
no no no
it sounds like the union is doing it
are ready we'll send them over are you
going to try it is this the pitch that
you ask them to join then you hit them
with the dues well it depends on what
the benefits are
but we should launch a general strike
over here
the first time by the way that uh they
said they were going to create a union i
turned to john i said hey john i'll pay
you not to join the union he goes well
how much
i said there might not be everyone got a
price i'll split it with you guys
the problem is you can't bust the union
because there's no substitutes for your
brothers so
facts well we have two other brothers
but they won't come on camera so no no
but they won't come on camera so we're
good unless there was like a big
paycheck and then they probably would
immediately the union knows what we're
doing don't worry
who's in charge of the union by the way
john i co-host
where can we send people let's send
people to uh your twitter anywhere else
that uh that you want people to go
twitter's number one uh if you want the
full archive of my content that's my
personal website nick carter.info
all right um that's where everything
goes
follow nick on twitter you've been
you've been coming after some fun
recently i've seen tell them what you
said before you got here john if there's
fun you'll find it
that's a compliment he said he's like
nick carter will find fun anywhere on
the internet he'll take a task i was
going to try and tackle some fun tonight
actually about you know some of the
stuff i said about the texas grid you
know some uh some phd environmental
science came at me yesterday really you
hate to see it what did they say they
said that the math was wrong but his
math was in fact wrong
let's go see this this is where uh
[Music]
the best part about the fun busting is
that it always goes back to like super
provable things like math
if you're gonna create all this flood
just stick to things that aren't
provably like it's like transitory like
it's the greatest flood in the world
because you say transitory nobody can
measure yeah it is transitory it's not
nobody can disprove you nobody gets to
be the judge there's nobody who's like
well if it hits 5.6 like no it's just
transitory and literally if we have high
inflation of over five percent for three
years the transitory camp will say see
it went down it was transitory like like
it's the ultimate
fun but the you know one of the
beautiful things about bitcoin is we can
actually retire one of the fuds like the
fud can be over which is the china
thought yeah oh well
well actually not quite there's there's
one person that uh still is gonna hold
on to it but other than him
someone said uh [ __ ] busters in the chat
so [ __ ] busters
i mean the china fight is almost over
but now we have the usa fudd
is there too much hash rate in america
which i'm not going to apologize for i'm
proud of america being the number one
usd
well
it always comes from very interesting
people and i think ultimately if you
strip away the like nuance uh
micro arguments and just say hey are you
just anti bitcoin they're always going
to find something new yeah right and
it's like oh you guys are taking
renewable energy and you're acting as a
sponge right and then it'll be like well
we think that uh it shouldn't be windy
and you're like what like they'll just
continue to find it yeah people actually
complain that bitcoin uses renewable
energy which would otherwise be used by
the grid which is actually just not the
case not true but you know the problem
is the critics don't invest the energy
in learning about how the grid works so
um i can't get them to learn
i can't believe i'm gonna bring this up
real quick as we're ending but i'm gonna
do it did you watch any of the clips of
sanjay gupta going on joe rogan's
podcast i saw some yeah okay so i
watched three clips or each two minutes
there were the ones that were going
viral online
and my biggest takeaway was actually a
correlation back to bitcoin which is uh
the people of which the media puts the
most um kind of validity on their
commentary
who only exist in that world
become exposed when they leave the
controlled environment totally and like
i don't know much about sanjay gupta
he's always seemed like a smart guy to
me you know very medical focused not
kind of politicized whatever from what i
could tell and that was my biggest
takeaway was wow i'm watching a clip of
him in like a longer form conversation
very different than the guy that you see
on tv in 30 seconds and i think that the
bitcoin critics are very similar they're
very good at what's the 30-second hit
but if you get them into a nuanced
conversation it's
a massacre and that's why we need
alternative media
bbb that's why you got to keep growing
the show i mean like you really do
because there's a crisis of confidence
in our our media elites and our
authorities we need alternatives
john is uh going to run for mayor of
miami as well when suarez has done he
said you stand in miami right i'll vote
yeah all right he says he's gonna vote
for you
less than one you gotta ask for the vote
for you we have time to change we gotta
get on my vote
i'll be here it depends how the union
goes yeah
all right that's it for today we
appreciate everyone watching make sure
that you like the video make sure you
subscribe to the channel nick will be
back at some point
i don't know maybe we'll make it regular
we'll see and uh we appreciate you guys
watching any any last words
union boys i appreciate nick saying that
we need the best business show it's
necessary i like that well if you showed
up to work more than once a week then
we'd be good to go this is why we need a
union i'm tired of these remarks
i appreciate you i appreciate nick jordy
matt the audience thank you very much
pay i said you pay off your credit card
he pointed at you
all right we'll see you guys later
[Music]
you